the Border bill it's not really a border
Bill they're calling it a border
security bill but it is a disaster it's
basically funding for Ukraine to the
tune $60 billion funding for Israel and
$20 billion for amnesty I guess the bill
basically just codifies exactly what it
is the Biden Administration is doing it
it creates an easier path for Asylum
Seekers quote unquote to be granted
Asylum and to be given work permits this
was the play it was obvious Joe Biden
screws up the border and basically
creates a mess then when Republicans
start complaining Joe Biden says I need
I need a bill then when they put
together a bill giving Biden everything
he wants and destroying the Border they
call it a security bill so when
Republicans in the house not the Senate
oppose it the media will run rampant
screaming the Republicans are against
their own bill that was the narrative
and that's exactly what's happening so
we'll talk about that plus we got crazy
news depend depending on how you view it
the federal government has sent a memo
calling on the Alaskan National Guard to
deploy to the southern border which
would include Texas for support for
Aviation it's a single grain of sand in
the Heap of things are kind of heating
up the last time this happened as many
people are claiming it's routine this
happens all the time yeah the last time
it happened was 5 years ago under Trump
and it was 10 Personnel we're now seeing
20 Personnel it's either the most toned
deaf thing imaginable the most tonee
thing you can do at a time when the
state is in 14 States basically had a
meeting all their Governors came
together saying we will secure the
Border against the Biden Administration
Joe Biden has threatened a deadline
against them and now you've got the
Alaskan National Guard coming down to
work with CBP on the border and this
does include Texas as part of their
deployment naturally there are already
attempts to claim this is nothing don't
worry about it but it's a grain of sand
and I think it's it's probably bad
precedent but we'll talk about that plus
uh I want to talk about this rumor of
RFK Jr running on the libertarian
tickets and maybe and then I want to
talk about Michael rapor leftist
comedian well liberal comedian who ABS
he's not a leftist he's a liberal
absolutely hates Donald Trump has now
made several videos talking about how
he's gonna vote for pig dick Donald
Trump so we'll talk about uh him he's a
funny guy but he's Fair liberal before
we get started my friends head over to
cast brew.com to buy the best cup of
coffee you'll ever have as Alex Stein
right here screaming because he needs
the coffee we got all the best flavor oh
man we're sold out of oh here we go
ground cof we've got appalachin kns that
stuff appalache nights is selling so
crazy and rise with abto JR we we did
not realize how popular and how
delicious everyone would find this
coffee I knew it was good cuz we all
work together to make it and now once
the people have discovered just how good
it is it is flying off the shelves so if
you want to support the work that we do
we sponsor ourselves you buy cast brew
coffee at cast brew.com and uh you
support the work we're doing we're going
to be having an event at the new
location for the coffee shop probably
March 5th for a limited number of
timcast.net M so don't forget to also go
to
timcast.net
super lowkey but we're we're going to be
likely doing maybe even once a month
live in person in Martinsburg West
Virginia but it's a private thing it's
just Members Only not a public Affair
it's a private only thing and so make
sure you are a member at timcast.net go
up our members will get the notification
first and as a member of course what
does your membership get you aside from
access to the uncensored shows as a
member of the Discord you can call in
and actually talk to us on those
uncensored shows and you're making all
of it possible you'll also get access to
those ticket sales if you want to come
and hang out but uh we really do
appreciate everybody who supports our
work so smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and everything else is Josh Smith
hey what's going on Tim thanks so much
for having me back I appreciate you
absolutely who are you what are you
doing I'm the host of break the cycle
with Joshua Smith live uh in the
evenings on on YouTube and uh I'm a
president uh candidate for president of
the United States for the libertarian
party right on so it should be
interesting we got Phil hanging out
hello everybody my name is fonti I'm the
lead singer of the heavy metal band all
there remains I'm an anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary and Libby's hanging
out hey guys I'm Libby Emmons I'm
hanging out I'm with the post millennial
glad to be here and of course sir just
pressing all the buttons yes I am back I
am here it's going to be back uh I also
see a friend of mine across the table
here
up yo I made it back I'm back from Miami
what's happening everybody welcome back
I feel good man I got out out of town I
went to Miami and I'm like yo you want
to talk about a culture War being in a
place with a bunch of people that you
don't necessarily agree with and you're
not the one curating who you're going to
hang with and hanging with them for any
long time anyway and just being with
those people that's like Frontline
material that's it's it's really
invigorating I was just in La for a week
and so was Libby Libby was in California
yeah I was in California for a good
stretch I was in LA working with Prager
on something and then did you step in
any poop uh no but I did keep saying to
my son hey hun don't step in the poop
hey watch it don't step in the
poop we were in LA and San Francisco and
we actually we had a spectacular time we
were uh we me and Alon were hanging out
at MGM National Harbor all weekend and I
had some stories early in the day about
this Trump derangement Syndrome guy but
there was another guy who was a fairly
liberal guy who was like I don't like
Donald Trump we got to vote for Biden
blah blah blah but he was complaining
about the poop he really he was like
he's like have you seen they got this
map the social media app where you can
see all the poop and I was like you get
it why would you want to vote for these
people I don't know man poop and death
it's like two things in California the
politicians fell upwards that's what
Gavin Nome they wanted to cover the
whole state and poop so let's uh let's
jump to this story we'll get we'll kick
it off with this Huffington Post
headline it's a betrayal Republicans go
ballistic over bipartisan border bill
they demanded this is the game everybody
who knows anything about politics
predicted exactly this Biden comes out
and says I need a new law to secure the
Border Republicans and Democrats in the
Senate come together and create an
amnesty bill which codifies exactly what
Biden is already doing it's not it's
there's no negotiation here it literally
just gives Biden everything locked in
nailed in Bang and so when House
Republicans are like yo no the media of
course was always going to say the
Republicans are lying obstructing and
this was part of their plan Donald Trump
wants chaos this is what they're saying
they're saying that the reason why in
the house they're they're they're
calling this bill done an arrival and
they won't vote on it is because they're
terrified of Donald Trump and Donald
Trump wants chaos so he can win the
election it is the long con but here's
the reality we've got this uh post from
Mike Lee US senator for Utah who says
the dirty dozen disasters in the
so-called border deal codifies Catch and
Release allows up to 1.8 million illegal
aliens to enter before temporary closing
off parts of the Border it funds
Sanctuary cities and NGO sending
illegals around the country it
subsidizes free taxpayer funded legal
council to
illegal to illegal aliens it expands
parole instead of limitting limiting it
it increases green cards by 50,000 per
year for five years work permit for
adult children of H1B Visa holders
immediate work permits to every illegal
released from custody after they pass an
initial screening nothing to deport
illegals Afghan adjustment act creates a
pathway decision for over 60,000 poorly
vetted Afghans who are brought to the
country due to Biden's disastrous
withdrawal weakens Asylum screenings by
codifying Biden policy no immediate
funding for the wall and now I love how
Mike Le said this is bad for the Border
what it doesn't mention is 60 billion in
funding for war in Ukraine or I believe
it's what 14 million for funding for
Israel 74 in total 74 billion in total
for between Ukraine and Israel so and
that's it's the whole bill is only 120
billion so I mean you're talking 20
billion for border and then it's it's
basically a war power
bill Foreign Wars funding zero dollars
zero laws and zero policy for border
security well and the craziest thing and
and Libby and I were talking about this
before the show started
uh if you read through the bill and I I
don't know why Mike Lee's not bringing
this up and other people but there's
there's a portion of this bill there's a
provision in this bill that gives the
the right for the all of these things to
be heard in the the DC District Court
going forward so that means found it
yeah it's going to give them on 150 yeah
it's going to give them where can i p I
think uh page 150 do a search for
judicial review it's right there at the
bottom page 150 all reviews on these
matters will go through the district
court in in DC in the District of
Columbia so they will have free re Reign
Over all of these issues from now on in
in DC the biggest problem the biggest
problem with the bill the existence of
the bill is the Republicans allowing it
to to be debated is giving TW
credibility to the argument that there
is a NE that the bill is necessary in
the first place the federal government
has all of the authority that it needs
to take care of the Border there does
not need to be another bill there
doesn't need to be new new author ation
from Congress there does not need to be
anything except for the executive to use
the powers that he has and to handle the
job given assigned to him in the
Constitution one of the few things that
are specifically said that the president
has to take care of I just want to give
a shout out I asked Libby to tweet out
the bill so I could pull out the DC
provision uh but Libby retweeted Mike
cernovich he said if the Border Bill
were truly a compromise Democrats would
support it as a standal loan rather than
tie it to the $60 billion WTF to moneya
laundering Ukraine it's all about money
money laundering but uh I just I just
love the WTF like 60 billion it's a it's
it's done you it's it's over it's it's
remarkable that anyone in their right
mind could try to justify this this
expense well mean me just sent it to you
meanwhile Ukraine's like uh you know TW
forcibly enlisting females to fight
their War because they're doing so badly
I it's at least a month now yeah so
they're they're forcibly enlisting women
to fight their War because they're doing
in Ukraine yeah well women are already
fighting in Israel for sure that's like
part of the deal but the situation in in
both Israel and and in Ukraine is like
these are these are arguably existential
threats right so like if the
Palestinians had their way there
wouldn't be an Israel and if the if if
Russia has its way they might take you
know at least half I mean can we can I
can I point out that when I said 14
billion to Israel that includes
Palestine as well right CU we're funding
both sides of that war absolutely and we
have been for clowns like damn fools
we're dumb as I mean anybody
anybody who's watched our foreign policy
in the Middle East for the last I don't
know three four five decades knows that
we always fund both sides of every war
then we never
lose Schumer Schumer is saying the
children of of Gaza will starve and like
come on we all know when you send money
to these NOS it funnels up to Hamas as
soon as these resources go in Hamas is
the Gover in body they take it why why
are we playing this game and I'm not
saying like pick aide I'm saying neither
let's come back to America baby fact the
fact that we're talking about it is so
frustrating because there is absolutely
no legitimate reason for Ukraine and
Israeli funding to be tied to
controlling our own border it's so
godamn frustrating it just shows the LIE
right I mean it shows the lie so clearly
you don't care about American
sovereignty you don't care about
American National Security you really
what they really don't care about are
Americans I mean when I talk to liberals
when I talk to conservatives everyone's
like yes this a little too much this
whole immigration thing is too much you
have you have uh officials in New York
saying it's going to destroy New York
City and everyone's like oh let's just
do that anyway let's destroy New York
City let me let me read this this page
150 of the bill it says judicial review
not withstanding any other provision of
this act judicial review of any decision
or action in the section shall be
governed only by the United States
district court for the district of
Columbia which shall have sole and
original jurisdiction to here challenges
whether constitutional or otherwise to
the validity of this section or any
written policy directive written policy
guideline procedure or implementation
thereof issued by or under the authority
of the secretary to implement this
section long story short you guys want
to know what this bill is it's corporate
it's trying to corporatize the American
government by giving diplomatic control
to the federals they're trying to make
sure that Donald Trump will have no
power to do anything about the border if
he becomes president they said
constitutional or otherwise meaning
we're going to do it whether it's
constitutional or not if we sign this
bill well and it's I mean listen I'm not
a lawyer that let's let shout out
because really really quick let's let's
read that again it literally says
whether constitutional or otherwise yes
now I'm not a lawyer and I'm not you
know super versed in legal East but I I
will say that sounds to me like we're
you know giving full Reign to DC to make
well we're not the thing to though is DC
already has full rain over a lot of
stuff like we already know that Biden
didn't need a border Bill to do anything
he signed all of this open border
nonsense into executive orders and
various actions within his first couple
of days in office you know that like
huge numbers of Border measures saying
we're going to increase the number of
Asylum Seekers we're going to let in
we're going to give everybody a court
date we're going to instead of remain in
Mexico we have remain in the us for as
long as it takes and now this border
Bill what it really does is it says
we're going to get more border agents to
process more people faster we're going
to get more immigration judges to give
more people Asylum faster there's
nothing good in there the record was
10,000 per day this says if it reaches
8,500 per day then we'll move the rest
to a legal Port of Entry what wait wait
wait wait they're not saying they're
going to stop them they're saying after
8,500 the rest can go apply at a legal
Port of Entry and it removes the
requirement for courts in many
circumstances well and you saw what
Chris Murphy said right Chris Murphy
who's one of the uh architects of the
bill said that under this bill the
Border never closes he said the Border
never closes so what kind of border
security is this if we can't even close
our own borders well here's the thing
too so I don't know if I don't know if
you saw this but if you saw this bill
you'd be criticizing every portion of
this bill if it came across your desk
and you actually had the time to read it
before toe but Matt Gates who you know
for all intents and purposes is a pretty
decent guy most of the time on some of
the stuff but he uh he came out and said
he he came out and he said uh uh you
know why don't we just defund un so we
can uh fund Israel I said I had I had a
post to him I said I said Matt you you
realize this this this isn't Israel
right we don't live in Israel You're the
America first guy what are you doing you
know um but yeah it's this this whole
bill is from front to back just terrible
there's nothing about the UN is we fund
the UN and the UN hires a bunch of
people that are linked to Hamas and
station and puts them in Gaza to
distribute all of the aid to Hamas but
but this is this is where we can find a
compromise how about we say all right 60
billion to Ukraine but no more funding
to the UN ever no funding to you know
this is the last one like you you you
you tie it to something what what what
did I say um the general idea is you tie
it to Something in such a way that it
puts them in a position they can't
maintain we'll fund the we'll fund the
wars that they want if we can bulldo all
of Washington DC listen 12% of the
population 12% okay if we can pull those
easy I'm in uh no but 12% of the of the
population in the United States having
problem put food on the table today and
we're sending $60 billion to to Ukraine
why why it's it's this well because
Cher chally it's money laundering it is
money laundering and like he threatened
that if we don't do it then he's going
to send our kids to go fight in eastern
everybody everybody that's in in office
now needs to get fired I wonder who
November needs to be an absolute like it
must be a massacre everybody that's in
office if you're an incumbent metaphor
Mass I wonder I wonder who they I mean
you know we're talking about the vote
let me let me pull up this from the
post-millennial Chuck Schumer demands
border never closes bill pass or else US
troops will have to fight in Ukraine
hold on hold on let let's we got to
break this down he did not literally say
Ukraine he said in Eastern Europe in a
NATO Ally in a few years and so it's
it's vague enough first he could mean
Poland he could mean Sweden I think it's
fair to argue he might literally mean
Ukraine in that the the West wants to
take control of it and would absolutely
shove it into NATO if if they had to but
he's basically saying Vladimir Putin is
going to invade Europe and so we need
this border security Bill who's border
security Ukraine's it's a Ukraine border
secur I want to know how my border got
to Ukraine you know I
you know when we say how did our
freedoms get to the Middle East how how
did our border get to the UK fire them
all bulldoze DC salt the earth I truly
I'm coming to believe this hypothesis at
least I have the hypothesis that we are
in a slow coup that's been going on for
100 years man it's like a banking yeah
they're trying to do it not fast enough
to alert the people JFK like JFK the
Federal Reserve the business plot the
the there's so much there's so many
Foreign Wars that are proxy wars were
with money getting laundered away from
our country and like I mean 9/11 even I
could just go down a list of things I
find in my hypothesis that this is a
news show I'm not going to do that on a
news show but like the last 10 years
it's been like they're like make it
don't alert them don't alert them just
let's get the money let's do the covid
spending what they increased our budget
by like 20% our deficit by like 20% in
like two years this
look soft coup I mean there I I would
actually
suggest I I would ask at what point does
the government become the the the
functioning and in control government
right so uh Taiwan the official name of
Taiwan is what the Republic of China I
believe correct yeah and so many people
make the joke that communist China is
just west Taiwan because the original
government of China fled to Taiwan
they've maintain themselves ever since
resisting the Communists and so my
question is at what point after the coup
happened in the United States woodro
Wilson who knows the banker plot the
Federal Reserve 1913 that's a right so
my point is simply this maybe maybe the
Revolution was Donald Trump not that he
is a perfect guy not that he was the guy
but that he ripped the establishment's
power in Twain and they were losing
their minds they're still losing it
absolutely and so when everyone's like
they're trying to Stage a I'm like you
know the thing is the establishment was
in control the uni party was in control
then a bunch of people on the internet
made a bunch of memes and the reality TV
Real Estate Mogul wins and says don't do
War we're shying to get down secure
borders and then they lose their like
we've lost control of this that's why
it's funny when they say our democracy
they say Donald Trump is a threat to our
democracy they're literally saying that
there's a populist Uprising against the
autocratic control we've maintained for
Generations yep that's true it was um
George Bush senior in the 90s said that
we were moving towards a new world order
this liberal economic order was fading
into something new a global order um and
uh Trump got into office and canel the
transpacific partnership right away
three days in it was the if you look at
the investor State dispute settlement
clause in that trans-pacific partnership
it said foreign countries these
investors these Malaysian oil companies
can sue a state for discrimination right
if we chose not to buy a Malaysian
company's oil as American citizens they
could sue our country and as taxpayers
we would have had to pay a corporation
out that's what that transpacific
partnership was going to do to us and
Obama was on board and then Trump came
in and threw the garbage I didn't even
know if he knew what it was what what it
was doing I don't know if he stopped
something he understood he just knew
there were a bunch of people outside
yelling Trump and they had expressed
concerns about ourselves and act like
there's not so much foreign influence
today still in the United States though
I mean it's apex's arguably one of the
very strongest outside influences in the
United States today and it's you know
and it's not good for us as As Americans
especially when you're American first
person right um but Trump got in office
and immediately hired John Bolton so I
mean the establishment thing is kind of
no no I thinkal not great at hiring
Donald Trump it was really bad
understand Donald Trump thought he was
like I'll play ball and I'll get done
what I want to get done and they were
like no no no no no you don't understand
you live under our boot you know they
they the the joke is you know as soon as
you win the election you sit down in the
Oval Office guy from the CIA sits down
and just hands him sits down to Mr
President opens a middle of folder and
then slides a picture of JFK right
across the table and says we'll be in
touch and then leaves right we get it we
get it Trump is the guy who was like
what is this I don't know what you're
showing me why are you showing me a
picture of this guy and they're like um
we're letting you know letting me know
what I don't get it and they're like to
intimidate doesn't understand what I'm
trying to say to him he's like we're
going to secure the Border we're
shutting down the no Mr President we're
not yes we are on the bus and he doesn't
listen yeah so what I what do I think is
I when when Trump was running I remember
I was in DC Trump had a meeting with a
bunch of establishment Republicans they
did not want him the Democrats wanted to
be the pi Piper candidate Trump I think
genuinely wants to secure the borders
bring jobs back that goes against their
agenda and so he thinks when he gets in
now I'm the president I've got to play
ball with some of these guys I got to
you know there's favors we'll bring in
John Bolton I think think Sheldon
adelstein wanted a lot of a lot a lot of
favors absolutely and so then what
happens Russia gate and Trump I think
finally realizes bro you are being
tricked manipulated and lied to and you
brought in a bunch of dumb asses I don't
I question whether or not there is
whether there are
people in available to fill the
positions that are not currently like
already steeped in the bureaucracy right
like there are a lot of positions that
have to be filed and I don't know who
you go with that's actually someone
that's not you know that's not already
got their their you know significant
connections to to the existing
bureaucracy just because you know that's
my concern but Bolton is like
obviously let let me tell you in order
to hire John Bolton Trump had to drive
past a local prison drive past a city
dump all better people and go way way
down to the to the Pacific garbage G
where he got a submersible and went down
to where all the deepest trenches of
garbage have sunk and dig even deeper
than that and there's John we could have
dug up the corpse of meline Albright it
would have been the same thing
essentially and so yeah it's it's
terrible and and and so that was what
worries me about Trump too right like in
in 2024 should Trump win is like is it
the same thing going to happen um and
yeah and then that's great and I get
that but my concern is that a lot of my
young Republican friends cuz I have a
lot of friends that are Republicans tons
of friends are very excited about Trump
because of who the VP pick might be and
I think everybody's like oh it's got to
be somebody like V or somebody like uh
Christy gnome or somebody like that and
I'm like you realize that like 80 part
of the 80% of the GOP is still like
deeply entrenched like neocons and they
have to play to that part of the party
not the 7% like the it would be really
funny if Trump just like came out and
was like I've chosen my VP John
Bolton I think it's going to be somebody
along the lines of Nikki Haley I really
believe think Tucker man just I'll put
it simply for those that don't know uh
John Bolton has a long history of
working in administrations and just
wanting war and so he we had a quote uh
I think this was during the Trump
Administration he said something like
this time next year we will be
celebrating in tan and so he is a he is
just a neocon maximalist warmonger
character Nikki Haley ain't got nothing
on the war he wants Trump hiring him was
a mistake and then Bolton stabbed him in
the back yeah you could do the like hire
a cabinet of a bunch of successful
businessmen at this point it's like like
the founders did the founding fathers
were a bunch of successful businessmen
that got together and started and ran a
government together cuz they knew what
how to run things and they weren't
entrenched in the garbage musk for VP I
mean you're talking about getting not
born in America if you're talking about
getting people that are actually going
to satisfy like supposedly the other
side of the aisle the last people
they're going to be satisfied with are
people that are that are like you know
CEOs and board members of companies you
can't satisfy the other side satisfy the
other side of the island I would agree
with that we were talking about this uh
downstairs because this song came on by
um Passion Pit
and there's a line he has a song called
I took a walk and there's a line in the
song where it says we can rip apart all
the Socialists and all their damn
Texas and uh the left went nuts over the
song attacking the band and criticizing
them was like a cancel culture thing for
having dared said that and that the
point of the song though is it's about
the feelings of like his Elder his
relatives it's it's quotes from them and
things they have said he's not literally
saying he hates socialism he's just
saying like this is what the older guy
said to him but the left doesn't care
what's true they don't care about the
point of the statement or the message
it's just uh it's surface level it's
it's it's one one-dimensional thinking
so if you want to satisfy these people I
mean we were talking about this uh uh uh
just before the show and I mentioned it
in the morning segment about this guy I
was playing a poker and he had Trump
derangement syndrome down in DC and I
realized something my girlfriend had
said he was he was he was muttering to
himself he was screaming how could you
vote for Trump he would not listen to a
single word he asked me to name one
thing Trump did that I liked I said no
new Wars he keeps muttering he's like
you can't even name one thing I'm like
Abraham Accords he keeps muttering and
I'm like this guy can't hear a word he's
just sitting there they're so stupid
these people are so dumb they're stupid
and then my girlfriend's like he doesn't
know what the Abraham Accords are and I
was like ah there's no way for him to
respond at all he to what that means
because he doesn't know you can't
satisfy these people because they live
in a they live in a shoe box but
arguably besides the no new Wars that
the best thing Trump did was ex like
make people extreme on the corporate
news media being the enemy of the people
that's the greatest thing that Trump did
and and it was hilarious watching him
work I mean just you know the way that
he's able to just troll people in in
real life is amazing like that's great I
love that but I do I worry about Trump
too and what that means for you know the
people who get their hopes up for a lot
of stuff and then it doesn't happen well
in 2020 less than half a million people
came across the border and were
apprehended it was less than half a
million yeah illegal immigrants in 2020
in what can you really expect from from
Donald Trump too like what what what is
it that you think people are expecting I
I think well I think people first of all
the VP spot I think that a lot of people
are going to be let down when we find
out who the VP but that's not even when
he's president let's say he gets elected
and I don't know and you know people are
like oh it's going to be somebody great
I'm like do you remember who do you
remember who VP was last time I know so
let's let's say it's it's Trump bergham
I'm just picking like the least probable
candidate sure yeah what do people think
like what what what what what what do
you perceive as the hopes and dream I
think I think on the extreme side it's
that you know all these people are going
to go to jail right like this is this is
the revenge tour we're going to we're
going to lock up all these corrupt
people and and shut down the border and
we're going to end all the wars and
we're going to you know give all the tax
CS but that's what a lot of people think
but no no no no but like first I can
locking people up and arresting
everybody maybe some people might get
some
referrals you don't think that some
people won't get arrested I sure hope so
I I don't think it's going to be like
military tribunals where they go to the
clintons or anything I think it's going
to be like we're going to hear about
lawyers and we're going to hear about um
election officials there's going to be
criminal charges brought up by I mean
could you imagine if cash Patel was the
AG right there there would be criminal
charges I don't think it's going to be
like this apocalyptic thing no ending
Wars well Donald Trump is the best
president in my lifetime on on foreign
on for foreign war and pulling our
troops out of Afghanistan setting the
deadline for it I should say Biden
screwed that up trying to get our troops
out of Syria and uh no new Wars kind of
expanded the Syrian War though a little
bit when he when he did that too right
when he tried to get our troops out yeah
what how so didn't didn't we send them a
bunch more cash right after that
happened I mean if we are leaving and
and like if you came to me and said
we're going to pull our here here's what
Trump wants to do want to get all our
troops out of Syria and then we'll give
Syria some cash it's like okay but he
didn't pull the TR troops out no no no
he did he he he gave the order and then
the the the officials lied to the
American people people to him and kept
them in fair right that that's that's
mes look if if the only thing I could be
offered was vote for Donald Trump he
will take a dump on the floor of the
white house but he won't start a war
I'll take it done yeah that is a better
deal considering how many people are
taking dumps on the
floor to be honest Joe Biden is like
he'll dump on the floor in his pants in
in the you know everywhere he goes he'll
have to change his pants several times
he'll start several Wars and I'm like
well there's no upside Dage well also
none of us stupid to believe that Joe
Biden is actually leading the foreign
policy in the United States right now
right
like 23 they just did a poll they put
out a poll where only 23% of the
respondents said that they think his
mental capacity is good enough to be the
president again and and that's I mean I
think that's high I think 23% is high
but that's really low in a poll for this
country well you heard what uh what Bill
Maher was saying Gavin Newsome's a
winner he can win an election sure uh
Joe
Biden man you know the argument from the
Sand's people that the only reason or
one of the main reasons they don't want
Trump is Trump is a loser he's going to
lose everyone hates him and uh it is
true the only reason Joe Biden won is
because people vote against Donald Trump
I I take that back not the only reason a
a good factor in why Biden actually got
votes was not because anyone liked Biden
but the strong factor in white Biden one
was because activists went out and
collected ballots they mailed ballots to
people and then people were told how to
vote well I I'm telling you listen and
then they told us that wasn't happening
the United States is really big on
politicians failing upwards we've known
this forever and coming from California
I watched Gavin new some Ruin San
Francisco San Francisco used to be a
really beautiful city when I was a kid
and he ruined it he destroyed it and
instead of going hey that guy really
ruined one of our coolest cities in the
state let's get rid of him we said let's
make him the governor of the state and
so we can have a poo maps for the all of
California and next who knows maybe the
maybe the country maybe the world maybe
the world why stop there Mars well there
there's a uh there was an article
written several years ago that I had
Covered California is 5 years ahead of
the United States uh over the past
several decades whatever happens in
California 5 years later is National and
so they talk about a bunch of policies
you know uh gay marriage was a big issue
in California things like that uh
illegal immigration Sanctuary cities
became Sanctuary States for a sanctuary
state for Trans kids well California had
Sanctuary cities which then turned into
a sanctuary State and then all of a
sudden you start seeing it spread across
the country and I I think it has a lot
to do with the un uh undue influence
they have through illegal IMM
they get extra votes yeah oh yeah
there's no doubt yeah they they have
extra some some members of uh Congress
have said it's between five and seven
extra congressional seats which is five
to seven extra Electoral College votes
for president because of noncitizens
they have illegally allowed into their
country and Defiance of federal law well
and under Trump trump said that the
census should be should differentiate
between people who are here illegally
and citizens who are you know obviously
lawful citizens and that's what he was
aiming for and by Biden reversed that
within his first few days in office and
of course the reason is to get more
congressional seats for democrat-led
states that allow all that illegal
immigration I want to jump to the story
from the Anchorage Daily News February
3rd Alaska National Guard plans
deployment to assist federal government
on us Mexico border I love it I posted
an image of this and someone said who
knew Alaska was so based and everyone
responded Alaska assisting the feds is
not based so the gist of the story is
this that deploy a couple aircraft and
20 Personnel to assist with the with the
aircraft they say it's routine this is
uh they say uh major Ryan we bicki a
spokesman for the US Army's Joint Task
Force North said in a phone interview
that Alaska guard members would be sent
to any of four states along the border
including Texas and Arizona Federal
requests for states to provide border
assistance are issued regularly and have
become routine now I tweeted about this
somewhat uh factiously I said what do
you call it when a National Guard is
called up to go against against another
State's national guard and I got
community community noted onx where it
took selective uh excerpts from the
article to obvious skate what's actually
happening it said they are not going
against each other I'm like I asked the
question intentionally to you know not
to State it definitively but it is true
these these individuals will be
providing assistance to CBP in Texas as
well as but that does mean Texas that
does mean part of their deployment will
put them up against Texas I don't know
how to describe it if Texas National
Guard is saying no to CBP back the F off
and you have no jurisdiction here or
we've cut you off from your jurisdiction
how in any way could you interpret any
amount of National Guard being called in
by the feds to a variety of states which
include Texas anything other than they
will be as part of the deployment
against Texas National Guard It also
says they also said it's a routine thing
many people responded saying it's
totally routine it's not that big a deal
yo it says in the article the last time
they did this was 2019
5 years ago is not routine no now I'm
not saying Joe Biden got on the phone
and said we need to bring the national
guarden to stop Texas I'm saying it's a
grain of sand in a heap and the question
is is this the most toned deaf move you
could possibly make when the Texas
National Guard has deployed armed
soldiers to physically remove and bar
federal agents from removing border
barriers or was it an intentional CBP
needs assistance because of what is
happening with look I'll put it this way
I don't care what state they go to CBP
and Texas are completely at odds as to
how to operate this when we had uh we've
had people who have reported on the
ground at the border tell us when uh
Taylor Hansen was here he said tens of
thousands of people it's chaos there's
litter what happened after Texas took
over three yeah he said he said four
four to six maybe and I said thousand he
goes no no no no four to six like four
five or six and I was like you mean like
on my finger for yeah four people I'm
like when what so when CBP is
facilitating human
smuggling and then Texas steps in what
do you think it's going to mean that Tex
the the the Alaska National Guard is
assisting them it means these people
these individuals who are providing SEC
assistance through with uh with Aviation
to the CBP will be at odds with the
mission of the Texas National Guard
that's a fact and I'll and I'll give you
one more let me see if I can find this
uh I had this I'm surprised alas would
send them to be honest and Dunley
because it's I mean that state kind of
already hates the FED anyways they're
like super that's like one of the states
that's actually pretty anti-federal I
had the story pulled up I lost it but
it's uh the the border patrol Union
supports the new border bill yeah
because they're getting yeah there's a
lot of pay increases and stuff for
Border guards in there but the Border
bill as we've previously as we cover
covered in a previous segment does not
have any security at all it in it
codifies
8,500 Criminal aliens entering the
country every day and gives them the
funding and it gives them more authority
to adjudicate Asylum claims without a
judge so of course they're for it do we
want let's say this law look they're
planning on having this law probably
passed I doubt it'll happen but if it
did and CBP is now in the legal is is
has legislatively legislatively been
given the right to bring in 5 to 8,000
criminal aliens every day and in some
instances determine their Asylum cases
just right there and they get work
permits a last National Guard is going
to be helping them do that and that's
still 3 million illegals uh illegal
immigrants a Year by the way which is
not a huge drop in what we're seeing
currently so it's it's not it's not good
none of this is acceptable I mean it
also though I mean the the the Border
Bill also has an increase in pay for
Asylum and Border agents the that's a
big part of it so I'll point this out
too in the community note it said it has
nothing to do with operation Lone Star
that's exactly my point operation Lone
Star is Texas's operation securing the
Border this mobilization has nothing to
do with that it has to do with
supporting Customs and Border Protection
in what they do which is the opposite of
operation lonar and so they are trying
really hard to downplay this move being
being made I think we have to point this
out because Alaskan governor Mike dun
leevy actually joined 24 other GOP
governors in support of Greg Abbott why
now would he like okay I guess no no no
we put pressure on them and say don't
you dare I don't care if it's 1 five or
20 I don't care if it's 200 we should
say no CBP is facilitating human
trafficking do not send
support yep it's all for show though did
you see what Abbott said he said that
there had been 3 to 4,000 people coming
across in a day and now it's gone down
to three yeah it's wild yeah that's what
it that's what Taylor hansome was
telling us he's T Taylor has gone down
shout out to tenant media he reports for
tenant Taylor was saying that he he was
there during the peak of the crisis
there's garbage in thousands of people
and then once Texas takes over four
that's wild and they've move if I
understand correctly they have moved the
locations to places in New Mexico and
Arizona theyve started to go into other
states which also makes sense for this
deployment Texas look Texas at odds with
CBP they have put up barriers and
operation loone star shipping containers
with razor wire all over them so the
criminal Enterprise is shifting
operations to other parts of Texas New
Mexico and
Arizona so what Alaska National Guard is
going to go help the human Smugglers CBP
at the Border in Arizona that is still
working against this country it's worse
than just working against
Texas yeah and so like the teth
amendment gives Texas the right to
handle their own border situation
anyways I mean at the end of the day the
Border BT would get rid of that yes
exactly that's and that's the goal I
think that's the goal cuz the 10th
amendment gives them the right what
they've moved the deadline on the the
the cut off deadline from Biden what
three times now has it been like three
times they can't do anything they can't
do anything they the the the
Constitution gives Texas the right to to
B guard their own borders they could
guard their borders from any illegal
Invasion that they want to because it's
not mentioned that that power is
strictly given to the federal government
so what does the 10th Amendment say it
says that that anything not mentioned
expressly for the federal government
here in in the constitution is what is
it article 4 section 4 states that the
federal government must defend from inv
now you got now you got this bill that
the National Guard can respond with Le
lethal force on the border yeah but they
can litigate they can what is an
invasion all day long for my point is
when you've got photos and videos of uh
human traffickers with rifles to the
point where Republican has proposed a
bill that would allow the National Guard
to use lethal Force against these
individuals I'm like uh I kind of think
when they're smuggling humans with
weapons into our country and many of
them are flying the flag of their home
country and like they have guns I would
call that an invasion sure did you guys
see Brett Weinstein tucked to Tucker
Carlson he went down to the Darian gap
which is this area south of I think
southern Panama between most dangerous
like 60 miles of jungle where this is
like where most people meet their maker
when they're trying to flee here they go
through the D I don't know most but a
lot of people die in that jungle and uh
he said he saw camps lots of camps and
they were very friendly one in
particular very friendly and they let
him in and he was talking to people
they're they're fleeing economics
they're not fleeing political Asylum
there's economic Asylum which is not US
Government first of all is not supposed
to take people for economic Asylum it's
not a real thing because it displaces
our own economics secondly then Brett's
like yo and then I went to this camp and
it was a Chinese camp and they wouldn't
let us anywhere near it and they were
what I would call hostile wow so what I
think is happening is that there is an
economic migration happening but it's
masking an invasion think of it like
this I think that's I think there's a
good chance of that yeah there there's
something that people don't are that we
don't talk about or people don't bring
up much that I heard someone discussing
today was the one child policy in China
that went on on from the 70s I think it
was until like just a couple years until
recently there are you know probably a
couple and I'm probably not exaggerating
but I don't know for sure but I imagine
it's probably a couple hundred million
young men that have nothing to do and no
women China needs to do something with
these guys womed on top of everything
else little girls were borted before
they could be born yeah and and so these
guys young men that have nothing to do
they start civil wars
they start they cause all the problems
societies run into it's always young men
that have nothing to do and don't have
women they don't have I want to clarify
for we got we got a super chat so I want
to give some clarification because
they're pointing out that it says
potentially deployed in early 2025 I I I
think it's important that people know
that but I don't think it changes
anything that we're we're talking about
right now it's it's it's toned deaf
right now to make this announcement and
the other thing we talked about earlier
in this segment is the point of the
border security bill uh one strong point
is that and and why they're starting
Wars they want to make sure that
whatever happens if Donald Trump gets
elected they steamroll through what they
want with or without him and lock him in
place so he can't change anything about
it announcing this deployment early
means that if Trump does get an office
he'll have a harder time stopping it
from happening can we I mean can we talk
about how crazy it is that we're bombing
uh Iraq again for 33 years and we want
to open the Border completely I mean
we've destabilized so many regions in
the Middle East and we're like yeah come
on in it's totally cool no one's no
one's going to worry and and also when
people come in right we have this uh
part of our culture now is to tell
everyone that America sucks and
everything that America stands for is
bad and that the culture part culture
that's part of American culture right
now not my culture yeah well that's part
of the culture of the nation in which we
were born and raised that's that has
that culture has been taken over by
really bad actors who hate America and
hate ameru it's a cultural revolution
and so we have people coming in and you
have all of these progressives saying
your culture is better than ours so
don't bother assimilating don't learn
English don't learn our values don't
become part of our culture and that's
not how it used to be when you had like
the Ellis Island you can call them who
you can call them what they are they're
Communists it's the Communists that did
that you guys love poker tables it is
you will get kicked out for speaking any
other language but English I have fun
hanging out watching you guys play poker
that's fun Yuri bof warned us of this in
the 80s I mean he defected from Russia
and said hey the Communists are taking
over every single one of your
institutions your libraries your schools
your government your hospitals all of
for profit mental health care what about
the banks but the the only only but the
only reason that matters have they
overtly taken over the banks probably
yeah the only reason it matters that
they did this is that we no longer go to
church but to be fair the Communists are
taking over a lot of churches too yeah
that too I mean there's a there's a
church right up street from my house
hanging a giant rainbow flag in front of
the church said what is that liberation
theology yeah I'm like what are you guys
what are you worshiping here man I mean
this is not I mov to West Virginia and
the churches the church I go to is full
yeah I'm a I'm like a I'm converting
Orthodox currently because they're like
the one church that hasn't cucked to the
Communists yet do do you uh go to that
one that's like downtown
Charlestown uh I don't want to say on
air
okay where you go to church at see you
there yeah there's one that see every
Sunday with my child right Sheamus would
go there and uh really nice and I told
the story of how like
we were going to go grab food and
Sheamus was like yeah I got church and
I'll be at it this time I was like cool
meet up and uh you know I show up with
my brother and I'm just wearing my
clothes and I see these like little kids
playing and they're dressed very nicely
and I was like
man something got lost yes you know and
it's not about in my opinion it's not
about uh being Christian and believing
in God although I think there's a strong
correlation between these things
Community is huge community and um
what's the right word I guess uh deor in
a sense decorum Community manners
feeling like you're part of something
like the church I went to in Brooklyn
where I really liked the you know I
liked the other people there I I taught
CCD there and I liked them but they but
they um what do what does that mean
sorry CCD CCD it's I forget what it's
called but it's basically where you
teach your teach the kids Catholicism
and they go through all the sacraments
so they start young and they go through
catechism yeah they you go through for
Orthodox Church too yeah you go through
all the sacraments you have like you
know um CCD is so you can get confirmed
as an adult in the church yeah but like
you do you have to do it for Orthodox
Church confession and um communion and
Confirmation and blah blah blah but um
it was very like there was there was a
Spanish mass that had all the families
at it and there were a ton of kids and
the whole Mass was in Spanish and then
you had the English mass which was just
a lot of old people and hardly any kids
and we don't speak Spanish you know so
much the pity I guess and we would walk
out of MTH and like all the families and
kids were coming in and like we weren't
part of that mass and I found it really
frustrating and I would say to the you
know I would say to the leadership of
the church we should do one giant
bilingual mass and parts of it are in
Spanish and parts of it are in English
and they'd be like well we won't all
understand what's going on and I'm like
we it doesn't matter if we know what's
going on or not the only thing that
matters is that my kids and your kids
are all hanging out you know trying to
get in trouble playing under the pews
that's all that matters that's what
matters and that's the only thing
they're doing to get in trouble right
that's great you know like my son
recently got in trouble because he was
at CCD and it turned out um it turned
out that he and his friend cut Mass like
they do CCD and then they have masks and
the mom my son's friend's mom called and
was very upset that the boys had cut
mass and I I'm thinking like yes that's
important they should not cut Mass
that's a problem I'm also thinking this
is great this is great like this is what
you're doing you you are rebelling by
cutting Mass I am thrilled in Brooklyn
like what are you doing you're like
getting high on the street corner and
robbing people here you're cutting Mass
this big deal yeah well I'll say this
before before I move on um I hope he's
not watching tonight yeah I've been I've
been I've been uh I've been saying this
for a while you know the Communists the
two things they have to be at war with
all the time is a strong family unit
unit and and Faith right because when
you're when you have those strong ideals
in your family or in your church
Community then it you don't just
automatically cuck to the communist you
don't say oh we need this this
collectivism to save us right what was
it video games or TV cuz it was like the
'90s when things started to fall apart
because that's when people started to go
when I started to go inward I could play
a game by myself for 10 hours alone
without talking to someone I had books
before that but if I ever played with
toys like Legos or Micro Machines I it
was way better to have a second person
to play with a book obviously I was
always alone and it didn't make me
communist but video games made me very
disconnected from human and then a lot
of online games it's not about being
kind it's about like talking online
well that's what the schoolyard is too
the kids are talking
too bad is it video games that I
don't want to I don't think it is video
games people disconnected it's in the
schools it was all of the stuff all of
the the socialization stuff all of the
the basically all the Socialist
influence that we have now it's all in
the schools it started in the'80s and
and that was when it first kind took
root Peggy Macintosh is 1989 uh what's
his name Palo frier and and the P what
is it the pedagogy of the oppressed and
stuff these all these all of this stuff
became the predominant way that te that
teachers learned so this stuff got into
the schools that teach teachers so that
means that every teacher all those
teachers went all over the country so
they're in
Oklahoma these teachers these teachers
are the teachers that teach the teachers
right so you you get you get it at the
very Source you get them into an
ideology that is based on an
oppression oppressor oppressed Dynamic
and you can apply that however you want
you can apply it by race you can apply
it by gender you can apply it by any way
you want but once you get that framework
into the education of an of an entire
generation it just starts pumping out
people that are ideologically possessed
that have the same worldview which is
people we it is our job it is
government's job it is our job it is
society's job to make things equal and
that's why you get people that want
Equity you want to have people that have
uh equal equal outcomes and that's just
turns into socialism let's jump to this
story we got this from Sports Ka some
libs are waking up internet reacts as
comic Michael Rapaport says voting for
Trump is on the table after seeing
migrants beat NYPD I want I just want to
say this uh real quick I can't remember
twet it might have been Michael malice
so apologies if I don't get the the
attribution right but someone said
imagine what it must feel like to be in
the corporate press where after nearly a
decade of calling Donald Trump a fascist
far-right white supremacist you find
that most people in this country intend
to vote for
him I I I I saw that cernovich that was
maybe not I know what you're talking I
know that twe so so it's a great it's a
great point to be made the power of the
media narrative is gone they can say
whatever they want about Trump nobody
cares and now you've got Michael
Rapaport who spends his time or spend
his time complaining online about Pig
dick Donald Trump that's what he would
say over and over again and now he's
made a video saying voting for him is on
the table and it's because uh it's a
really fun video it is there's a bunch
of issues but mostly this past week you
got illegal you got criminal aliens
beating cops hold on let let me start
over you got criminal aliens mercilessly
beating NYPD and Michael in Midtown and
they get arrested and are released right
away Alvin brag who has charged Donald
Trump with like 30s something felonies
won't even say what the felonies are
released these guys and he was like uh
we couldn't tell from the video exactly
who they were but did you see this thing
Tim McConnell is now saying don't don't
don't vote for the bill McConnell saying
don't vote for yeah be really bad
McConnell saying don't McConnell is
telling Republicans to block the L
Schumer borderless Bill jump to that but
let me let me let me play the Michael
rapor video I don't know is it too crude
let's uh oh it's fun I think he's funny
I think he's a funny guy think this is
why when I say voting for pig Donald
Trump is on the table voting for pig
Donald Trump is on the table wait wait
why is he censoring dick the other day
in New York City six illegal aliens
jumped a New York City Cup in two
of finest they jumped to new New York
City Cup in Time Square and were
arrested and released without bail I
know it's a city thing I know it's a
state thing I know all that I know all
that I know all that okay stay with me
released without bail came out of the
courtroom on some Tupac raising the
middle finger with the Detroit Red Wings
Jersey tell you what the is the
world coming to if you could be from
another country be up a cop in New York
City and walk out with no bail what the
is the world coming to what the dude
he's right like yeah Alan Bragg needs to
be impeached but this is not just like
some cops got to a fight dude I have
seen occupy activists push a cop and get
assault on an officer charges and
they're in deep trouble these people
like Michael R has come from another
country assault officers and ain't no
big deal I I said it last time I was in
the show and I want to say it again um
there one of two things that's happening
here with Michael raport either a uh the
Biden campaign stopped paying him um or
or but but we have McConnell saying not
to vote for this bill and Michael
Rapaport saying that voting for pig dick
Donald Trump is on the table maybe the
adrenic Chrome supply has run out and
these people are starting to come back
to to real life maybe it's true you know
I think that that's probably the case
reason is Not an Accident reasonable
people are the reason this country
exists in the first definitely not adren
it's not
a reason is taking hold of these people
this is why I said that line about
imagine what it must be to be a
corporate journalist who for a decade
said Trump was a fascist white
supremacist and today people intend on
voting for the guy more than half the
country that's why you know I love
telling the story about the dude I met
in DC who had trumped Arrangement
syndrome because part of me next time I
encounter something like this I'm not
going to try and argue with the guy give
a point I'm just going to say I'm on the
right side of History that's what I'm
gonna say to him I'm gonna say I'm on
the right side of History you're on the
wrong side of History we got we got the
polls so you're in the weird minority of
weirdos who don't watch the news I don't
know what you're going on about Michael
rapor if he's saying it w we won think
about think yeah like I mean to Tim's
Point like think about how many people
like when they get into the voting booth
and they're you know they've got they're
you know they're alone they'll actually
vote for Donald Trump right they they
would never admit it but when they
actually got into the booth they they'd
actually check for Donald Trump if
people like you
know like this guy are making
articulating that it's O acceptable to
conceive of yourself voting for Donald
Trump I feel like there's probably a lot
of people that that this gives them
permission you know what I mean people
that don't feel confident this gives
them permission to vote for a Trum
exctly they feel like now I can someone
else said it I can do this and and he
noticed too it's not just me I'm not
crazy maybe joh Donald Trump that that's
that's what I think a lot of people feel
like so the next time I'm at a poker
table and some guy with Trump
derangement syndrome starts yelling at
me me I'm just going to go listen I'm
going to tell you why voting for pig
dick Donald Trump is on the table
because New York City's fests were beat
up uh let's play the rest of the video
the is the
world you're from Brownsville brookin I
know this like what the f have I gotten
myself into stay with me on the same day
that that happens kadav Joe Biden issues
an executive order about 4
quote unquote settlers in Judea Samaria
aka the West Bank some troublemakers
three of the four have already been
arrested you issue an executive order
about four
troublemaking UPS who've already been
arrested in Judea Samaria while there's
a war going on while there's 100 plus
hostages still being held in Gaza you're
talking about that but you got nothing
to say about
beating up cops in New York City the
greatest city on earth maybe it's not
maybe my city is not the greatest city
on earth
anymore here here's the important thing
he's wearing a star of David one of the
one of the things that really shifted
rapor was the Israel Hamas conflict and
when he's coming out and being like why
is Joe Biden more concerned with the
West Bank instead of our cops that's
like that's a h deal crap like the first
thing came out was what's going on with
these activists who are anti-israel now
he's actually like yeah I care about
Israel but this year is more important
he's being pushed further and further I
want to give him a shout out last time
we talked about him he had that he has
that really funny video where he get hit
that with a snowball the funniest video
online I know it's one of the best cuz
he's self-aware I think he's a funny guy
and I respect it what if the whole thing
was just a troll though it was the the
the video of him getting with the
snowball no I mean prior to that all all
the all the about him you know
hating the right and pig dick Donald
Trump and all that what if it's all just
just a big giant call it would be great
if he just came out really calm like I
just want to say to everybody that I I
never really hated Trump I just thought
it was funny to yell and and make fun of
him and I'm voting for him and thank you
so much and they put on a magae head
yeah after this video I'm almost
positive that they they took his bag
away he's not he's not getting money for
the Biden campaign anymore for sure but
but yeah I uh one of the big points
takeaways of this was he's actually mad
that Joe Biden focused too much on
Israel that's the crazy thing you guys
hear about uh uh Biden say Netanyahu is
a bad dude or whatever yeah yeah I's
trying to win these votes back yeah I
think I think that was clearly leaked
just to try and appease the progressive
left and get them back on see I think
Netanyahu is not amazing too you guys
right we're all on the same team still
you know he's a bad D run some bad boys
but I think that was such a that was
like such an obvious dumb leak
purposeful I think once you've won over
Michael Rapaport it's like that's that's
that's it but this actually it's a good
point you were saying Phil about giving
permission because I made the joke about
being at the table and saying you know
next time in public I'll say something
like that but I guarantee there's
probably a lot of guys who are default
liberal don't pay that much attention
but have been given permission now they
can still insult Trump but they can be
like yeah Pig dick Donald Trump you know
but I gotta be honest man like I might
vote for him because dude like Joe Biden
and he's a cadaver you know what I mean
yep they can't they they're not going to
be able to put Joe Biden up in this in
this election something's going to
change soon would they give them I mean
who would they put up instead everybody
hates kamla and she only has one phrase
you know who you know who it is it's
going to be the the Antichrist uh Nome
from California that's you got there's
got to be a way to get around Camala
though and Camala is literally
cryptonite to a white male Progressive
what is he going to say how is he really
be but she makes absolutely no sense she
do it does not matter she is look she
everyone knows that she is like the
worst absolute worst person the the
Democrats could possibly feeli but at
the same time they can't do anything
with her they can't attack her she's the
first woman uh she's got multiracial
multiracial I mean multiracial female
Untouchable and if you do she absolutely
will turn it on you and call you you're
the racist you're the blah blah blah she
will use that at the drop of done I
think that's done I not on the I don't
think anybody cares about being called a
racist Harris withheld evidence when she
worked in San Francisco she withheld
evidence that kept somebody on death row
like a lot of there's like a lot of
black aggressives who hatea Harris
because she locked up more black people
oh way more black you know based on like
but she also withheld withheld purposely
withheld evidence knowing that somebody
was innocent to keep him on death row
none of that matters none of that
matters to the left at all I don't even
think that she has the ability to see
what can be never mind being unburdened
by I believe it's going to be Nome I do
I really believe that he's going he's
going to do something don't see I just
tell me how they get him how do they how
do they get her out of the way tell me
how they do it and maybe because I don't
think that Nome like I think that
Newsome is is far more of a threat to
not only to the United States but to the
to like Donald Trump and to Republicans
but how do you get him into the position
to run well you'd have to get her to
resign but she's power hungry she only
had 3% of the vote when she was running
the Democratic ticket you know when she
was trying to trying to get that ticket
yeah look like I
said not it's I don't think that Cala
Harris is good but I just don't see the
I don't see the path to get her into the
position yeah let's talk let's uh we'll
jump to the story from CBS News oh boy
RFK Jr mulls running for president as
libertarian as he struggles with ballot
access so tell me has to get nude to do
it I I I I will say this I have I have
heard some people who are uh libertarian
party members associated with the mises
caucus nothing from high up just
mutterings from you know regular folks
that this is their big push and they
really do want this yeah I'm curious is
is it true and what's going on yeah I
believe it is I believe they do want it
whether whether they want him to get the
nomination or not they definitely want
him to jump in and shake up the the
election there's no doubt about it I
think I've seen grumblings from several
people in the mes caucus in including
you know my good friend and I I just
made a video about this 5minute video
about this that I put out in public so
it's not like I'm saying anything that I
haven't said but um I think that Heist
and Angela the chair of the the
libertarian party as well um we've seen
her make comments that show support for
an RFK libertarian run and the problem
is is I don't think I don't think RFK
can get our our delegates to vote for
him and make them not Liberian well he's
terrible on every issue except for one I
mean really he's been you know what's
the one good issue well the healthcare
Freedom stuff I mean the guy healthare
Freedom yeah he's a he's a medical
malpractice lawyer I mean that's what he
that's what he does right so like he
came from you know litigating these
really high-profile Medical malpractice
cases and so like of course Libertarians
are like yeah Healthcare freedom and but
he's like the Homer Simpson meme with
the all the fat pinned up behind him you
know where it's like and socialist
monetary policies and he's an eco-
fascist and he hates guns and it's like
and he wants to rename Columbus Day to
indigenous people oh Jee it's you know
and he's and he said directly you know
if if the house were to bring him a bill
Banning the Second Amendment he'd be
happy to sign it he said that how did he
how did that come out he publicly has
said that what was the what was the like
he's been anti- forever listen this gu
this guy's an old school Progressive I
mean not Progressive he's an old school
Kennedy Democrat he's good on a couple
of things he does he does hate the the
Deep State the so I don't believe that
he knows what the Deep state is when did
he say that uh sign a bill you got to
look it up I've seen it a million times
though um let's see look up Kennedy I'd
be happy to sign Second Amendment I you
know I considering the the performance
that he just had on Dave Smith's uh
podcast three months ago vows to respect
Second Amendment not take it you know y
yada gun control cannot meaningfully
reduce gun
violence comes out against gun control
in June he all of them are basically
anti-gun control but he is a liberal on
them I mean I suppose the issue is if he
said years ago something like that it's
important to been saying that stuff for
a long time right it's important to
bring that up and now that he's running
and he knows it's not a popular issue
with moderates he's evolving on the
issue well yeah you know he's going to
say whatever he wants to say to to to
get elected but what the problem is is
here he didn't understand what running
is an independent would would be like as
far as ballot access goes right we're
talking $100 million to get ballot
access across the country as a
Libertarian party we spent $2 million a
year fighting for ballot access in like
three or four states and and we've are
pretty you know established party as far
as third parties go we the the the third
largest party in the United States or
the fastest growing party in the United
States and and he didn't realize like oh
this ballot access stuff is really
really hard you know and so he could
come over and get ballot access with the
Libertarians but the problem is is he
doesn't share any of our values at all
and Libertarians are very sta about
their values there's one state you guys
don't have New York you don't have New
York yeah wow how why uh so so Larry
sharp actually ran as governor and got
the required amount to get us ballot
access there and the the legislature
went and changed the rules after that
took us off B oh that's low that's it's
New York that's what they do yeah so
what so the the libertarian candidate
for president is not going to even be on
the ballot in New York we can't there's
a possibility it's likely to cost us
about $300,000 or more that we should
raise that money we're working Larry
Sharp's running a whole campaign to to
you need to raise how much I think it's
like3 or $400,000 that's a lot of money
but there's also caps on how much you
can give right right exactly but it's
not to a politician it's a political
party though yeah I think a pack you can
donate a lot more than just to like
there's 33 like for a federal C Camp
campaign right now there's 3,300 uh uh
individual donor cap right now but I
think with a pack and stuff like that
which I think they're working with you
can donate a lot more money to them but
yeah it's a lot of money and and it's a
lot of work and they need petition and
they have to get out and get like they
Chang the the the amount of petition
signed that you need to like some
ungodly amount so um and they don't have
a whole hell of a lot of time to get it
done yeah so it looks like um let's see
there might be the Party Committee state
district and local
unlimited and uh National National
Committee it's unlimited yeah that makes
sense if it's that mean our National
Committee you can just I mean we had
people donate like a house and I mean
you can donate but I mean if if the
libertarian party needs 300 Grand to get
on ballot access not doing great
financially right now that's actually
surprising to me that the libertanian
could not must I mean how many how many
Bitcoin Creos have well here's the thing
the libertarian party has been existing
on like $1.7 million a year budget for a
decade so it's not like it's a they of
money bigger before a decade ago no uh I
think the biggest we ever were were in
2000 when Harry Brown was the the
candidate um and he actually doubled the
size of the party membership I don't
know that that um meant that we had more
oh I'm I'm sorry I'm wrong I'm wrong an
individual can only give the party
$10,000 per year 10,000 yeah right I was
reading it wrong yeah for for for
individuals and then pxs can give like
way more money no no no no it's
41,321 300 I think it used to be 30 now
that I'm thinking of it I think it used
to be like 35 60 but they've upped the
the cap on these things they did for the
the presidential election too it used to
be like 20s seven or something now it's
3,300 that an individual can give uh
where do people donate to the party
lp.org
um how many petitions do you need to get
in New York I don't know I don't know
Larry sharp is the man that would know
that he's running the whole I think
we've had him on a couple times yeah
Larry's been here for yeah he's and he's
been a Rogan and stuff he's running for
governor right he did he's not running
for governor currently um and and I've
been trying to get him to jump in the
race to run for VP um but now Clint has
announced that he's running for VP so
that's R ladies gent Russell is running
to be VP for Li yes who do who do you
think's actually well I you want it I
want the no I'm running for president
right that's what I mean I mean I want
Clint to be my vice presidential cand
okay right there's no doubt about it uh
who do you think's going to get it uh
right now there's it's like kind of a
four I shouldn't ask you that way ask
you who's the Front Runners who's the
front runner yeah it's it's me uh Chase
Oliver who's kind of like the left
leaning social Progressive libertarian
but he has some good policies too but
he's like the gay guy who always talks
about lgbtq rights and stuff like that
um there's also Lars mapstead who
actually founded uh Adult FriendFinder
so he actually helped create this
terrible only fans culture that you see
in America today um so he's the loaded
candidate he's got Mill millions of
dollars and then of course Michael
rectenwald who you've had on the show as
well as the me guy so that's interesting
I've been asked about re rectenwald a
lot by a lot of people I meet outside
like just out in the streets or whatever
who Libertarians they'll be like oh what
was recton wall like and I'm just you
know but I find that interesting it
seems like he's got the name recognition
he's uh I don't I mean I don't see it
he's only raised he only raised 20
$1,000 in the last quarter so it's not
like he's getting like a ton of play
what about you have you announced a
little bit less than that yeah okay do
you do crowdfunding uh yeah I mean we're
raising money at at Joshua Smith 2024
comom you man it's it's it's kind of
wild how successful the uh libertarian
party is despite its like sing budget
it's a twoing budget yeah and they put
it together and and worked really hard
and and it is the fastest growing party
in the country and I think that you know
we're not going to win the presidency in
2024 I talk about that all the time like
not with that attitude no but anybody
anybody any libertarian candidat it's
like we're going to win the presidency
in 2024 is just lying to themselves
really I mean but we do have the
opportunity to you know with with Ark Jr
though he gets you past a certain
threshold it with the so there's so that
we talk a lot about this 5% threshold
which I actually found out means minor
minor party status it's like 15% to get
in the debates of course if we poll at
15 in any of the major polls they have
to put us on the debate stage that's
what I want that's my biggest and that
would be like in the general just
polling to the general not even in then
general election so like if we pulled at
15% there's a requirement for for the
debate Comm
to allow that party to debate so we
would get on the stage with you know
whether it's Trump or Biden or Trump or
new some you'd have a Libertarian up
there saying all these things RFK Jun
yeah yeah an RFK Jr Dave Smith VP
ticket would you be would you be VP for
RFK Jr no no I can't do it it would be
too much of a conflict for me see see
here's the issue I see with it if the
idea is you know you're not going to win
why wouldn't you just take an RFK junr
candidacy and just get the numbers
because then because then we we fool
everybody about what the libertarian
part is about we saw this with Gary
Johnson and Bill weld Bill weld said on
the board of CFR right I mean this guy
was he he was terrible on nuclear energy
was terrible on all kinds of stuff that
Libertarians support and um so him and
Gary Johnson went out and they talked
about well there should be some minor
restrictions on the 2A and Hillary
Clinton's really a great service uh
public service and this and that and so
we got this like huge influx of
membership for Gary Johnson that all
ended up being like the left leftist
like social Progressive Libertarians and
once they realized that hey that's not
really what the party stood for they all
left the the social the social
Progressive Libertarians are probably
they probably have the worst to offer
cuz they're just the Democrats with no
freebies they're the Democrats like guns
yeah they're Democrats you can get guns
out of them and they're going to end all
your entitlement it's respect my
pronouns no welfare yeah exactly it's
all of the it's all of the bad things
about the Democrats and no and but you
get guns and you get you know a bunch
well the problem is that these guys are
like well we want you know and Jacob
hornberger who is running but has
totally destroyed his campaign is is
talks about this all the time like those
guys just want to like oh well Social
Security we just want to make a little
cut here and and the tax you know we
want the we want a fair tax and we want
to do that it's not like they're not
looking to try and roll back these
systems they're looking to like take
little cuts out and that's not good for
us either because then people show up
and they're like oh man you guys want to
you guys are like two-way absolutists
and you want to get rid of social
security for for the younger generations
and everybody's like well what's going
on here you know and so it's it's bad
for the party to have somebody like RFK
in my opinion but to the to the to the
upper brass on the lnc and some of these
people of course they want because they
want the money they want the donor list
they want all that stuff RFK might have
no choice he's horrible well and he may
not get on the ballot he's not going to
get on the ball he's not going to be on
the ballot in probably 35 States if he
really does want I mean it's crazy how
the Democrats just nuked his his
campaign well they had to they also you
know may have shot his uncle so you
think they were going to he was going to
win and but his
dad his dad too yeah jeez say like his
Uncle so he should be happy all they did
was nuke his his campaign really but no
it's it's the truth the truth is have
shot his dad yeah and his uncle yeah the
truth is is that he's probably as an
independent he's not going to be on the
ballot in like 30 something States and
he doesn't have the kind of money to to
to buy the ballot access but if he's
libertarian he automatically gets all
the ballot access any ballot access that
we have as a party if he gets the
nomination in may he automatically gets
our which is everything with New York at
the moment I think there's one other
state that we're working on but we're
going to get it I knew we were working
on Maine but Maine's we've got Maine now
we we hit the threshold so yeah I feel
like you come in raise a bunch of money
get it on this F and every state get 8
to 15% of the vote I mean he's really
popular yeah uh I I I'm looking everyone
leaves the party the next the next year
yeah but but if but if you if if I mean
I don't think the people who are in the
libertarian party are morons if the
party convention you're giving them a
Libertarian party a lock hold on hold on
hold on I'm talking about the mis's
caucus sure I mean if you if you've got
social Progressive weirdo Libertarians
your part's fractured and busted we've
gotten rid of a lot of them they' theyve
a lot of them have left so so you know
basically if the Mis party the Mis
caucus has taken over and everyone kind
of gets it and at the convention
everyone's like look this is not a
representation of true libertarian
values but it is an alliance between an
independent and a third party that are
trying to Democrat he's a Democrat even
though he's not a Democrat he's a
Democrat but you got to you got to you
got to come on you got to compromise a
little bits he's an independent running
right now who's shut out from the
mainstream who has an opportunity to
team up with a third party and both are
trying to to to smash through the front
Gates of the establishment sure so I see
I understand you might say he's bad but
if we combine you know with our powers
combined in your party Tim whatever
third party this this this non-existent
third party that I'm making up currently
that you run Hillary Clinton comes to
you no no no no no Hillary Clinton's The
Establishment with all the power and
she's in position sure but your party
needs money you need donors you guys
have to compromise wrong analogy it's
it's the same policy you are you asking
me it's the same policies though there
there RFK is not Hillary Clinton come on
policies same policies I mean the
policies are almost IND discernable he's
an eco- fascist he wants to shut down
businesses that that uh ref he wants to
go to war with Russia well he wants to
go to war in the Middle East for sure
RFK Jun want go he's been talking about
it yeah absolutely look it up he's
changed his stance on on the Warfare
stuff so much over the last 6 months
especially since October 7th right like
big time Big Time so uh yeah man I mean
he's he's not he's not great on these
things anymore uh e fascism is pretty
easy to turn people on if you make him
aware to being able to reuse the carbon
it's so reusable this guy has has said
specifically said he wants businesses
shut down that don't go along with the
climate uh agenda that's pretty rough
he's bad on saying with draw from the
Middle East to come back to America to
start working oner what date is that his
website right now okay that's not what
he's been saying in the media though
well look my point is simply this like
it is not fair to compare RFK Jr to
Hillary despite the fact we can agree
that RFK Jr has bad policies across the
board okay Hillary Clinton is is is I'm
trying to think of anybody else Hillary
Clinton is voting for like that's like
literally voting for the bureaucracy the
problem is is that this this person
holds none of our values right and so
we're going to put him in jener are hot
no absolutely not if I had a political
party and jener came to me and said look
you've got a lot of people who are
behind you and we get the poll numbers
I've got a l of people behind me if we
if we came together and everyone who was
between the two of us knew the point of
this was to just drive a car straight
through those front Gates and this means
y'all are on the debate stage next year
I would say yes and not like I I I
actually said if it came down to like
Mitt Romney versus uh like Mitt Romney
versus Hillary Clinton and Jen yuger was
there I vote for Jen why at least he
pardon Julie nange I guess what am I
supposed to expect with the with the two
of the unip party establishment I'm not
saying I like his policies at all I
think the dude's actually fairly crazy
and he's not an American citizen my
point is simply look man people come to
me and they say Trump did this bad thing
and this bad thing and I'm sitting here
just whistling being like no new worse
and they're like yeah but what about
this bad thing and this bad thing and
I'm like yo this country has been
riddled such bad things from bad people
for so long and then I'll tell you this
if somebody comes to me and they're like
I'm running for office what are you
going to do I'm going to I'm going to
clean up the streets I'm going to clean
up crime I'm going to restore America
make it really really great I'll be like
that sounds pretty good what else you
going to do I'm going to go bomb foreign
countries sorry have a nice St I'm not
voting for you I you can you can talk
about securing the board you can talk
about bringing jobs back and then you
say but we got to intervene in the
Middle East and I say I'm out because I
know what that leads to in terms of
inflation what it leads to in terms of
death blowback conflict crisis all of
this stuff and I've witnessed some of it
you get Donald Trump he could literally
come out and be like I don't care about
anything domestically I don't care about
any American I don't care about you I
only care about me but I won't go to war
I be like okay I'll take it military
command man that's their number one job
how they going to command when I get
when I get these people saying to me
like this guy the other this this couple
you know the other day and he's he's
saying all the stuff about how bad Trump
is and he's a liar and I I love it he
said every business Trump has ever had
has gone bankrupt and I'm just like well
that's just literally not true but I'm
like I don't care I don't care if the
dude was in an alley slinging no I'm
like no new Wars you know let's deal
with our problems internally and we'll
have to so long story short if and I
understand your position I'm not telling
you you're wrong I'm saying like for me
I see the point where it's like I I I
see RFK Jr as a guy who's wrong but I
see him as a as as as a good dude just
he's just wrong like Marian Williamson
is a is a good person she's just wrong
and if we could team up and
fundamentally change the two-party
environment we've had for Generations I
mean that is is a grand slam sure well
then listen great with Robert Kennedy
but why not any other libertarian
candidates right like you have a giant
platform right and other people have big
platforms and you're all sick of the
wars who's who's pulling it his
numbers they could be if they anybody
could be if they got the if they got the
visibility that he's had right and this
is the point he's a Kennedy he's a
Kennedy yeah but he's got visibility
people know who he is right he's got the
name recognition he's got the visibility
and so this is the point the libertarian
party needs a boost here's a guy who who
was booted from the Democratic party and
and and cold shouldered trying to court
Independence I not saying the
libertarian party should bring them on
I'm saying I see the case for let's fund
I see the case I see the case too I
understand the case I think the case is
wrong and I don't think the delegates
are going to put him in that place I
agree with on that I'm not I don't want
to tell Libertarians they should vote
for compromise though it's a big part of
politics is compromising With the Enemy
have you ever met Li it's gotten us to
be the most powerful country on Earth
libertarian have you ever met a li Arian
and spoken to them
compromise Libertarians are known for
their purity tests if you even if you
accept the existence of the post office
you will be excommunicated from the
libertarian party do not test them do
not test them would you say can we can
we just real quick would you say that
the that compromise has gotten us to
where we are today well is the the
United States can we just show Ian this
meme the compromise of all 50 states
this is this is a meme from Simpsons and
uh it's Edna kopel Skinner and Willie
and they say he says brothers and
sisters are natural enemies like
progressives and Libertarians or
Communists and Libertarians or ancaps
and Libertarians or Libertarians and and
other Libertarians they ruined damn
Libertarians they ruined libertarianism
and then Skinner says you Libertarians
sure are a contentious people you've
just made an enemy for life that's
libertarian pretty much it yeah that's
how it is nobody hates Libertarians more
than other Libertarians the very truth
of our existence I just I just love that
story about uh when they when when they
asked about whether or not you you you
should be able to sell heroin to
children and I think was it Gary Johnson
said no and they booed him yeah they
booed him and that was and yeah and that
was so that was in
2016 when they had this this huge caucus
in the party called the audacious caucus
and they were like all super like
offensive uh not even ancaps like
leftist really and and so um you know
the the parties changed a lot we we got
we got rid of the uh the abortion plank
they kicked that out so there's no more
like room for error there um and then
you got guys like me who are running who
I consider myself an America First
populist libertarian candidate right
like I don't I don't believe in open
borders I don't believe in abortion I
know that I know that we've had this
debate on the show several times but I
don't believe that you should be able to
sell heroin to 5-year-olds I don't
believe that doctors should be able to
force push kids towards like mutila
surgeries and stuff like that I think
they should be prosecuted but I also
believe that the Federal Reserve has
destroyed the economy and the Warfare
state has done nothing good for any
Americans and these entitlement programs
are destroying us and you know so was it
Austin Peterson who said it yeah it was
Austin okay wait I just Googled that
c-spans got the clip has no
constitutional authority to regulate
drugs that being said at the state level
I would support some legislation that
would stop children from being allowed
to purchase drugs and prosecute anyone
who would put a child in danger because
I do believe the children do need some
protection yes you should not be able to
sell heroin till a
5-year-old
face too Austin was by far to be fair
people were clapping for him in my
opinion Austin was by far the best
candidate that year too and he had he
was close I mean it wasn't far off in
the vote I think you need compromise I
just it's politics like I'm I'm an
idealist in my soul but in the reality
I'm more of a compromis like I'm down to
do things I don't want to do to get by
and sometimes like we're past that bro
and uh so you know I was a a a talking
to this guy the other day he said that
the libertarian party isn't libertarian
enough and I was like well what what do
you mean I was like it's Austin Peterson
got booed when he said you know he'
prosecute people selling selling heroin
to kids and he was like and he looks at
me and he goes abortion and I was like
yeah I think the Mis caucus are fairly
pro-life right is that is that true Josh
the misus caucus uh I think there's I
think there's a bit of a split there but
for the most part Pro live yeah and I'm
pro- life and I think heis is probably
pro- life and a lot of these people but
there are still some people who you know
think there's a good faith debate uh
effort on both sides of the debate and
this and that you say good faith debate
well I would I would that's the go ahead
I would say that uh I am not in the
pro-life camp but I certainly do not
believe there's a good faith debate with
the left on abortion right I think think
that there's not a good faith debate in
a lot of areas yeah there's a good faith
there's a good faith debate with people
like me and people like you or you know
uh I I really think it was a great
conversation I had with Glenn Beck on
the issue which I've probably evolved
quite a bit on it since then probably
moved a little bit further to the right
on on on a great deal because I have a
Libertarian stance on the issue of uh
the 14th Amendment and my position on
abortion is actually just libertarian at
what point does the government have the
right to determine someone must provide
their body to someone else and that I
you know I don't want to get into an
abortion debate but my point is yeah we
did this for like on the after show for
like an hour yeah I don't want to get
into it but my point is like that's
where the real debate is where we
actually are genuinely like what's the
Constitutional limitations what can the
government do and then you have the left
that they're just like we just want to
kill babies yeah it's bad it's gross
it's it's like uh they're you know
they're basically sacrificing their own
children to molok dude that's really
what it is I can't I can't put self
correcting problem it's yeah I know and
I and I have a lot of friends on the
right that say let your enemies do what
they need to do you know what I mean but
don't interrupt your enemy when they're
making a mistake you know so there's a
religious argument for me but there's
also like I think that the libertarian
argument so anyway the point I was
making to you is that uh compromise made
sense in the 9s when Democrats and
Republicans overlapped on almost
everything except how much taxes should
people pay and should it be this high
for this bracket or this low and you
know how strong should the Border be now
the issues are like Sanctuary States
should be able to K people should be
able to kidnap your children and bring
them to a sanctuary state where they can
get a four sex change right like I don't
see a compromise there and an abortion
at the same time more comp is just to
get the LP on the ticket I found I found
get I found the reason article with RFK
talking about uh so it's called RFK Jr
the reason interview and it's an actual
interview and he says I love Tulsi
gabard because she understands the
importance of disentangling or
unraveling the Empire and unraveling the
war machine so that's good but on
Banning assault weapons he said wait
wait wait can I I want to pull it up so
yeah it's the just look up RFK Jr the
reason interview it okay let me pull up
the quote Yeah but there's another quote
here where he says I'm not going to take
I'm not going to take away anybody's
guns but if a bipartisan Bill to do so
pass Congress I'd sign it right he also
assault weapons doesn't mean anything
anyway yeah there's I mean it's such a
vague but he's we've long known that
I mean you should you should sign off as
president I would never sign a bill that
constitutional but I mean I do think
that it makes sense to say you know if
this is what the people want you should
do this V St not an unconstitutional
thing
no you're missing my point I I I I hear
your point the border security Bill
bipartisan does not mean the will of the
people it means the corporate
establishment paid off a bunch of
crackpots or insider trading at the time
quotequote border security bill right
now is quote unquote by Artisan it's not
really bipartisan though Republicans in
the Senate did help them draft it my
buddy Chris who sent me article from I
will I appreciate you said the president
doesn't actually the the president
doesn't have any constitutional leniency
when it comes to the border right like
he he's charged with yeah he's charged
with this is your job with not allowing
an invasion yeah this is your job the
point of the presidency is quite
literally that if there is a bad Bill
from that's bipartisan he vetos itet it
that's well I mean yeah fair enough and
but but again we're talking about this
bill as if it's legitimate as if the
concept of needing this bill is
legitimate and it's not it's entirely
illegitimate this is a
distraction the fact that we've spent
you know that that you're spending so
much effort and energy discussing this
when the the the president has every bit
of authority that he needs currently in
the Constitution to to defend the Border
take care of all the problems we have at
the at the board the president has all
the authority he needs this is literally
just extorting the American people so
that way they can get money to launder
in Ukraine and give money to Israel to
defend their own country how are how are
they laundering money without Sam Bank
bankman freed I don't understand well I
mean it's they don't have their Chief
money laundering launderer anymore this
actually crazy I actually met uh a
lawyer for his family really I mean look
I got to tell you I tell these stories
about National Harbor uh DC and this is
where all these people are hanging out
you want to you want to meet the high
powerered Lobby I gotta tell you man
this casino is apparently the highest
grossing Casino in the country
it's I I can't even I don't the there's
there's just like 20,000 people
downstairs at the tables and they're
probably all Millionaires and I cannot
fathom I saw a guy sitting at a table
with like 20 grand just playing away and
I'm just like this is nuts you go up to
the poker room they had a I I guess it
was uh it's if I don't know if you guys
know anything about 25 50 was on the
list but apparently it was even bigger
than that long story short was that mean
it means everybody who played had to
bring $100,000 jez so you have basically
one and or more that's the minimum
that's crazy and so these are people
with a million dollar on the table I was
not playing anywhere near that level I
was playing 25 and I met a guy who was a
lawyer who was talking about how he's
actually a lawyer for their family and
uh you know he didn't he didn't go in
any classified details but it was
interesting to hear the perspective he
had on what was going on with Dr the
chares on that guy I mean it just seems
like
uh it's all dirty yeah I read that they
dropped some charges bu of the chares
they dropped some charges but not all
yeah they can't really put him in jail
when he was the one laundering their
money you I I got to say this I got to
say this right now I got to say this
right now um if you're a journalist
you're trying to figure out how to get
started in journalism I got a tip for
you guys cuz people often ask what can I
do to get started and everyone always
says buy a cell phone and go to the
Border I got a better one for you tell
stories it's a good idea go to the poker
room at MGM National Harbor it is it no
I'm not kidding the people I have met
there it is wild I mean first of all I
was hanging out with a guy who was a Mis
caucus guy the other day and he knew who
I was and he was like oh and we're
talking about normal stuff but then you
meet a guy who say he's a lawyer for the
bankman freed family and I'm like tell
me more good sir if you want to get into
journalism or I mean post-millennial
should just have a I I might do this I'm
going to H table I'm saying hire
somebody I might maybe we'll have scnr
hire someone literally just to play one
three and keep an ear open but really if
you want the the big shots it's two five
or five times are very expensive games
and it's hard but the things you
overhear there and the things people are
talking about because these are people
in DC who have a lot of money if they're
playing 510 that means they spent
between 600 and 2,500 to play that
game and I got to tell you these guys
they play more than that so you have to
wonder what job they have in the DC area
and it's not a construction worker no
you're going to find lobbyists and
lawyers and they love to talk you can't
film here though some casinos do allow
it but if you're in MGM National Harbor
does not and probably because these guys
are going to be high-powered lawyers
delegates political staffers people who
are uh doing things maybe they shouldn't
be doing but you'll hear those opinions
I'm willing to bet you will find a ton
of stories if you just play the game and
ask like oh really like what do you do
what is that like oh is it true what
they said about that guy you're going to
get scoops Galore cuz these dudes are
they hang out the table they're bored
all day they're there for 6 hours or
more probably drinking some of them are
a lot of them are drinking and the
server's coming around offering drinks
actually but if you go on the Saturday
night it's it's I'm willing to bet
that's a good spot for a journalist to
hang out Poker Room at MGM National
Harbor now all the all the DC
politicians are
going oh the ones you've had on the show
are like thanks thanks a lot well I was
saying I was saying before I think this
is where they actually launder money so
when uh when I played uh this past week
uh yesterday when I was cashing out they
had like a a supervisor come over and
and track the cash out write down my
name write down the table I was on the
game that I was played how much money
was played how long I was there and then
thanked me for my business and I'm like
I wonder if that has to do with money
laundering that's wild yeah cuz uh we
talked about it before if you want to
launder money if you're I was actually
talking to some uh some dude there about
it and he was like nah you don't need to
go to Poker Room for that bring up a
briefcase and I'm like how do you how do
you report in your taxes I came into 20
grand it's really easy you got a proxy a
guy who works for your company or just
someone you know who you want to have
the money and then you got a guy who's
going to make the donation and they play
a hand of Poker and then the guy goes oh
gez I'm going to bet 20,000 ah you beat
me right and there's no record of what
cards you had you just muck them so you
don't even know if it was it was a con
game all you see on camera is two guys
played a game of poker and one guy won
20 grand now reports on his taxes clean
as a whistle right and we really and we
know what that money is really for I've
seen Ozarks I've seen the I've seen the
show that's what they did the show right
I mean that was the big thing I haven't
seen those yeah they open a they open a
casino so they could launder cartel
money I mean that was that was the whole
thing about the show so the poker room
is especially interesting you sit down
with your cash and then you say I'm
going to bet 10 grand and the other guy
says I call and then you go ah he got me
so so let me explain this let's say uh
here it can work really simply anybody
who plays poker poker knows how you
could do this but for those that
understand you don't need to show your
cards if I've got the best possible hand
let I get a royal flush I have the best
hand but I want Phil to be given money
Phil could have the worst possible hand
or he could have a hand and then when I
bet all my money and he calls my bet and
flips over a mediocre hand all I have to
do do is say he got me and then put my
cards face down in What's called the
muck no one will ever see what I had
which means I can choose to lose without
any proof that I actually won I wonder
if casinos in the future are going to
change it so your cards are always TR
yeah they could they could I mean they
can record it they we have we have an
RFID table they could track it well they
I mean they make the they make the poker
hand uh cameras too for like the big
poker show now they do RFID where you've
got a little you've got it on the table
you get the cards and you rub them you
don't have to but you try to get them to
move reads and then the computer gets
all the information I don't think
they're going to spend $20,000 on an
RFID table at any casino and they're not
going to intentionally expose people
that are are trading money they're
interested in exposing money laundering
they have no reason to stop that like
some some I'm not suggesting National
Harbor does this or if is any way
knowledgeable of anything that's going
on good to Cave at that yeah I I think
is a fine establishment I just genuinely
I make sure we come dude I got to tell
you man I've been a lot of casinos okay
and a lot of people have but you go to
MGM National Harbor and I do not
understand how these people are are
there I I don't get it you want to play
one hand of like ultimate Holdem it's
basically it's like a black it's like
Blackjack but it's a different it's
table game we call carnival games it's
going to cost you let's see it's
505050 150 and then to play another so
200 bucks to see one hand and if you
want to raise your bet you got a good
hand you're putting another 150 on
top how is anyone playing there I it's
got to be people well I don't know
speculation they're like from a foreign
government they're like go to DC get the
job done and give that City 100 give
that City a million bucks while you're
there here's take take this 10 million
with DC National Harbor is a Maryland
mhm yeah how far from DC is it a couple
miles so it's like a hot spot a DC hot
spot but it's out of DC so this is the
thing I'm like I really just think maybe
it's there's a lot of big money come
there's no G arlingt no but National
Harbor is Maryland and it's just south
of DC and I'm like maybe DC is more
powerful it's not listed in one of the
top cities for millionaires it's
actually nowhere near it but there's a
lot of money running through there and
I'm see there's a lot of diplomats too
diplomats have a lot of money that must
be it but I'm like I'm seeing what looks
like some workingclass dude pulling $25
slot levers and I'm just like this is
the craziest place I've ever been
there's also people ruining their lives
with gambling I mean you can't you can't
take that out of the equation sure but I
don't know man you go to like Maryland
Live or gambling's like heroin to some
people man it really is it is bad I get
it but like I mean look if someone's
making like 80k a year they get their
one paycheck for the weekend they're
going to be there for 5 minutes yeah I
don't un I I don't believe that like
where all that big money is coming from
I mean maybe it's just the reality that
DC's got a lot of secret Millionaires
and a lot of money flying through and
people are going to go to the casino I
think seven of the top 10 richest
counties are the counties that surround
the DC area I I don't know about that
many but I think one of them like one of
the highest Fairfax is really rich isn't
it I don't think it's seven of 10 I look
I I was looking this up to try and
figure it out and it's like California
has the whole Chevy Chase area Marin
County is one of the richest counties in
the entire country I know that and
that's the right across the the Golden
Gate Bridge there a lot of gambling
there no and it's Salo it's all it's all
Bay territory the funny thing is L
County Falls Church Santa Clara San Mato
Fairfax Howard which is in Maryland
Arlington Virginia Marin County which is
in California uh Douglas County in so
yeah I mean it's not the seven but it's
got what's see one two three four five
are of the top 10 you're effective
Virginia or Maryland fun fact the Golden
Gate Bridge is uh one of the still
privately owned by a secret group of
people from is that right the Golden
Gate brid is owned by I don't know if
that's still the truth but that was the
truth for many many many many years yeah
it was like a secret secret group of
people from in Marin County that
actually in Mar County you don't say
yeah of course right all right we're
going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net the swatters and the
attackers and the activists from from
screwing everything up and jamming us up
and uh but uh you will uh help support
our work and we're having March 5th a
live show so this is in one month live
in Martinsburg West Virginia at our cast
Brew location which will not be open at
the time but it will be on the second
floor of the building our private club
not open to the public members only if
you are a member you will see the
notification pop up and if you're in
this I mean we're we're 1 hour from DC
basically so if you're in them 3 hours
from Philly two hours from Pittsburgh an
hour from DC if you're in the area and
you want to come check out the show be a
member because I don't know at what
point we will put up the tickets but it
may be like two weeks out or something
like that so uh sign up support our
support our work really do appreciate it
and before we read super chats I do want
to give a shout out to our good friend
Taylor Loren for one of the nicest
things she could have possibly said in
relation to my work I was deeply moved I
saw an interview she did where she said
Tim pool is dishonest
which shocked me
until she explained in Greater detail
what she meant she said Tim P does not
do journalism he comments on other
people's work and he is dishonest and I
went oh she's saying the news that I am
reading from The New York Times and from
The Wall Street Journal is
fake based I like the gist of what she
said isn't that what most podcast do we
like we look up current events and then
comment on sometimes when you say
something someone disagrees with they'll
call you dishonest but they just you
just don't you're not lying doesn't
you're she literally says in the
interview Tim Po does nothing original
he just comments on other people's news
and he's dishonest but if I'm
commenting on news the what's dishonest
it's not my opinion on the news right
because an opinion isn't a fact-based
question so she's saying the news is
fake she said the quiet part out loud
yeah I appreciate it we're going to read
super chats all right Steven says second
hello Josh in fact good sir you are
first stepen there you go Shane H Wilder
says the Alaskan National Guard will Pro
probably be deployed in the summer so
they can pass out in the Texas heat in a
Napoleon invasion of Russia scenario
well it may be early next year we don't
know exactly when the point is why are
you going to announce this I mean this
is a virtue signal and I haven't done it
in five years at the very least it was
just really a dumb timing at rert G
stanberg JR says Tim did you see Bill
Maher prove his incompetence once again
with pbd on his show when talking about
Gavin Newsome for president it was
painful I do not agree with the general
assessment of his performance what
happened is Bill mahs said Gavin Nome is
a winner I don't understand why we can't
have him Patrick B David said are you a
results based guy pbd he's so good at
what he does with these interviews and
he and Bill's like what do you mean like
well results you're saying like he's a
winner so what did he do to win and bill
says no he wins election
right then pbd says Patrick B David by
the way value tment says what did he do
that was good for California and bill
says he made it rain I don't care he's
like I'm there's bad things about
California I don't like everything he
does I don't actually see this as a
gotcha moment as a lot of people do
because Bill Maher was not trying to
make the point that Gavin nome's
policies are good he was trying to make
the point this guy is capable of winning
an election against Trump and Biden is
not and that is a true and correct point
we should be concern conern about if
they try to swap Biden out for gav Nome
however I do give some brownie points to
come on Bill don't cheer for a guy you
can't complain about Trump for being bad
and then say I have no idea what the
other guy's done but like he's like not
everything Gavin nome's done is good I
mean there's bad things of course what
does he done that's good I don't know
okay well now you're talking about Gavin
Newsome is a winner can win an election
and he's he's kind of bad but Trump is
very bad okay whatever I get it it's
probably a reason why Bill Mah does not
want to come on this show yeah I mean to
be fair he's like a super rich old guy
who's like doesn't want to go on
anyone's show also because you won't let
him smoke weed in here so we offered to
go out there and try and work something
out they said no oh really yeah and I
and I I will not go on real time I would
never I I can't stand that that's so
silly like it's just WWE about your
format man I mean I could easily it's
just like sit there for you know speak
for 10 minutes and then you're done and
then argue with some guy who's going to
say stupid things and get a rise out of
the audience
but uh Club random uh we tried like hey
we'll go to La we'll set up our show for
a week and then we'll come on the show
and they're like well you
know can't do it whatever he doesn't he
doesn't owe me anything all right let's
grab some more Mr Battalion says Tim
have you thought that AK is betting on
DT winning 24 since the deployment isn't
until 25 exactly all these moves that
are being made are to create crisis
under Donald Trump's uh presidency they
like they're not going to be able to
rush aate him again so what can they do
the this bill will give will give the uh
uh the federal government all of these
powers and it's locked in and if Trump
wants to change it it goes to DC federal
court right that's that's that was the
key you guys pointed out I was glad I
found that I've seen a couple people
share it now but it's not it's not
making the rounds like it should be
because that's probably the Crux of that
bill probably the besides the the war
funds that is the biggest part of that
bill and then what happens even if
Congress tries to change it will it also
have to go to a DC court it's what it
sounds like to me I mean like I said I'm
not a legal lease guy but it it sounds
to me like everything pertaining to this
issue from now on will have to go
through the DC I think Congress would be
able to override it themselves without
court but Trump won't what's going to
happen is Trump will get elected and
he'll be like we're going to shut it
down we're going to lock the borders and
then immediately Democrats will file
suit and say the bill the law of this
land says we have to go to DC Court
where they will immediately say
immediately say Trump loses and rap it
well and he's going to only if even if
he gets elected he's only going to have
four years they're going to it up in
court for two yep immediately minimum
two years in the DC district courts
people forget that you may win the case
but it's going to take so long for it to
get done it's effectively useless
especially in the DC District Court I
mean they're going they're going to keep
pushing it back pushing it back it's
there's all these other things are going
to take precedence it's going to be bad
let's read this one this one's good uh
Quan Xin says Shin want to clarify
something you said last Friday in
Singapore you can't get caned for
littering you can get caned for illegal
entry or overstaying your permit for 90
days that might help with us immigration
ISS isues yeah I'm yes bring back I'm
not in favor of but um I do believe that
atypical punishment that is not cruel
and unusual well I don't know atypical
and unusual I don't know what the
unusual means but I do think there could
be forms of uh Penance that would
actually be substantially more effective
than torture or locking someone up with
their gang yeah it's not you could do
cruel or it's not cruel or unusual it's
cruel and unusual pun is not if it's not
cruel it can still be unusual oh good
point and if it's not unusual it can
still be cruel like putting people in
prison where they get raped wow it
shouldn't be but I think the point is
cruelty is unusual I think it's the
point listen what happens to pedophiles
I don't care they can go to prison and
get raped all for all no no can't we we
could use some unusual like agree I I
agree with the atypical or unusual like
we talked about this like I guarantee
you if if I was given like you are the
Supreme Chancellor how will you End
crime in Chicago I would say when you
are caught for violent offenses we will
make you wear a
diaper and crawl around in a public park
surrounded by everyone with their cell
phone cameras filming you and you have
to say Gabby Gooby Gabby Gooby for two
hours
that's what is if you made him do it in
their living room that would be unusual
though maybe I like it in the par a mon
hold on hold on here's my question about
the definition of cruel I'm talking
about violent criminal offenders who are
caught convicted in a court of law and
their punishment is to be to be mocked
in public humiliated I think cruel needs
like torture is cruel solitary
confinement is cruel these things cause
tremendous like lifelong traumas and
physical disabilities you getting made
fun of for an hour or so is a like I got
to tell you in Chicago these guys are
going to be like ain't no way I'm
getting caught dude because they're
going to put you in a diaper and make
you
you got to hop like a bunny down
Michigan Avenue and everyone gets to
film you and that's forever you're not
going to go to jail but that's who that
that will be who you are and they're be
like I don't want to be that I like the
diaper IDE I like the public humiliation
aspect public humiliation was big in the
Puritan days wasn't it you had like
stocks and stuff they they'd put you out
in public or Hester prin with her a that
was
humiliated did these horrible things or
the lady who I forget what her crime was
but her sentence was to work at a fast
food restaurant y so uh I'm riding the
car with some skatebo ERS and some of
these guys from the south side of
Chicago is probably when I'm like oh 20
19 years old maybe and the way they
speak they say when I go to jail I'm
going to X they don't say if they don't
say I hope I don't they say when I do
yeah and the other thing is many of them
like that they've done it and they brag
about it yeah they go you ain't no you
know is where did you get locked up man
I spent x amount of time in this place
you're going to come at me bro it's just
like getting your wings in the military
man it's the same it's like something
you're proud of but but if they said
aren't you that guy saw in the diaper uh
uh Gaba gooing down Michigan Avenue and
everyone laughed at you he' be like no
that wasn't me I swear to God so so
there's a there's video buddy I'm pretty
sure that was there's a meme where
there's a guy there's a guy who's like
on his bed on the internet naked or
something and then someone tweeted
there's another guy who posted something
and someone tweeted him hey aren't you
that guy that's butt ass naked on your
couch or on that's on he like no it's
not me and they post a picture of it
people are terrified of that right and
so I'm not literally saying we should
have people dress in diaper I'm making
the point that the idea of locking
someone in a box with their gang and
they like it yeah that's not solving any
problems at all we're spending
yeah now there's and and there's a lot
of people it's not helping there's a
there there there'll be a guy who's like
I saw this in Ferguson so they're
struggling to pay their bills they're
driving to work and they've got a busted
tail light they get pulled over they
can't pay the bill so they don't then
they get pulled over over so there's a
bunch of small towns when you drive
through the St Louis uh Metro it's like
99 different cities and so when you
can't pay the bill it's like it's a
weekend in jail the only problem it's
two days no big deal right but if you've
got six tickets across six jurisdictions
they put you on tour it's where you go
to one jail two days later they
transport you to the next jail two days
later next jail I'm like how is taking
this guy to the workforce and stripping
him of the money he doesn't have helping
anybody because he couldn't pay a ticket
none of that solves any problems that's
not a good reason good and how are we
taking gang members putting them in
boxes with their gang where they're
happy it's happening and acting like
we're solving the problem in any way
like Bo Kelly you guys see he got with
90% people or so and there's apparently
like a well according to the news very
legitimate election but people love him
what is he doing to get the gangs off
the or is it just severe brutality in
Salvador right now they're arresting
them all and they're just putting all
these guys them in a brutal prison where
they just all sit there like Arkham
Asylum like it's the worst of the worst
of their society all together one Arkham
Asylum
basically that's what it looks like in
the pictures and they're terrified dude
so there are guys who have gang tattoos
and they're hiding in the shadows this
it's wild some of the stories I've heard
cuz like you join a gang you get a
tattoo on your face now that buelli is
locking up all the gang members they're
makeup covering it up they're panicking
like if I get seen associated with a
gang in any way it's straight to lock up
yeah yep I was talking to my Salvadorian
friend uh just the day in DC and he said
like he went back just recently after bu
elected he's just like night and day
like he doesn't even recognize his own
neighborhood anymore from when he grew
up as a kid so he the most violent
country in the world or at least in it
was it was up there definitely in top
five and it's now it's one of the safest
in the world yeah and and bitcoin's
legal tender right so and their economy
like all sick now this is uh Z Zev check
page 213 of the bill aliens from
non-contiguous countries shall not be
included in calculating the sum of
aliens encountered whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoo can you pull that up 213 aliens
described in subsection blah blah from
non-contiguous countries shall not be
included in calculating the sum of
aliens encountered what are the which so
which countries are they saying that if
you come from China to Mexico you're not
going to be non-contiguous means if you
don't touch if your country doesn't
touch the US
wow that is messed up you guys this Hey
listen this is ass call your call your
Congressman tomorrow everybody every
body that is not from Canada or Mexico
is not counting yep in that 3 million
year that will be allowed in this bill
is very important we got a Canadian
illegal immigration problem trying to
come in here Mexicans it for a while
guys we just had two people arrested we
two two illegal immigrants were just
arrested for running a human trafficking
ring across the Canadian border you
should out it's much easier to get into
America from Canada than it is to get
into Canada from America I heard someone
I heard I some podcast uh sit Adam were
talking about this particular phrase and
they were saying that they were thinking
that it might be something having to do
with Cuba but the way that it sounds to
me it it does sound like if it's not if
you're not from Canada or Mexico which
are the only two countries that are
legitimate that where the people could
make legitimate uh Asylum claims because
you're supposed to stop in the first
safe country that you come to if that if
it's the case then that means that they
that that anyone that isn't from Canada
or Mexico is is not counted so the
number could be you know God knows and
that's for the purpose of closing the
border so they won't have to close the
border if it's just all people from not
Mexico yeah so you could have like a you
know 5,000 people from from Africa and
they don't count towards the 5,000
people to to close that's what it seems
like that's what it looks like most of
the people are not coming from Mexico
not excuse me this bill is ass it need
to go away very quickly very fast
everyone should call their Congress
people all day all day
long like at 2 start at it doesn't
matter when it doesn't the time doesn't
matter just fill up their their their is
there a website you can go to where you
put in your area code and it shows you
who your congressman is well I mean
everyone you can go to your yeah you can
Google if you Google whatever your you
know I'm from this town who's my
congressman Google will tell you what
your district is I will say though Mitch
Mell coming out and saying so Mitch
McConnell is basically the guy in my
lifetime that has always been like oh
there's a there's a bad bipartisan Bill
coming through we should we should go
for it like you said that but I saw
something from tenant media earlier that
said that Mitch McConnell was for it so
I'm not sure if that oh I didn't say
that Libby said it so so if it's wrong
Libby was wrong not me I'm just I'm just
paring with liby why you lying to me why
you lying to me y why you wrong about so
much B mcconell saying to vote against
what I saw he didn't say that she said
she saw it so I saw it on I said I saw
it on Al I was surprised to hear that
because Mitch McConnell basically is
like I didn't claim it myself the bad
bipartisan Bill machine right like he's
the guy that's on the in the Republicans
it's like oh it's another bill that's
going to not help American citizens at
all sure why not every every time my I
barely see anything about him that's
like popular people are never really
stoked it's always something what are
you do in Kentucky get it together gez K
weird you have Thomas Massie and Rand
Paul yeah I know and Mitch McConnell of
all the people wild come on all right
Jacob says Ian I just want to thank you
your humanity and compassion and your
quick jump to assume the best in people
has given me hope about a year ago I was
depressed alone and without purpose I
considered ending myself many times you
and God saved me you know what dude I
was thinking this like yesterday that if
you if you live in fear even if you
succeed you failed like it you have to
have at least that positive like belief
in the Future Hope yeah yeah even if
things are bad like it be hopeful
man cuz things are going to get better
and live like that hope is what makes us
human Winston Churchill was great about
that during World War II cuz it was like
the darkest time in British history and
they people were getting bombed in
London they were anyway let's read this
ew says y'all need to go watch the Dave
Dave Smiths interview with RFK JR this
past week Dave 180 on RFK Jr the idea
that he would VP with RFK Jr after that
is hilarious go watch the interview yeah
he he wrecked he really I'm telling you
this was the long he was he was a fan of
rkade Jr I think he's I think he's a I
think he's a fan of the the The anti-war
Narrative that he had been having prior
to this Israeli palestini conflict
recharging obliterates AR he he really
he took him to task on all this stuff
real bad and in fact at the end asked
him do you think Israel has too much
influence on American politics and it
was the longest pregnant pause I've ever
SE it was probably 10 seconds somebody
made a video of it with the curb you
your enthusiasm music because it was so
long he was like uh
well and then he starts saying well I'm
not really a politician so I couldn't
tell you okay sure you could yikes I
will just say this Phil MTG reacted to
it and from punch bow yeah nobody owes
playing with you leave all right so
nobody owes us any favors if you don't
want to come on the show want come on
the show then you don't come on the show
that's fine but there are a lot of these
personalities who are terrified to come
on this show because they know you say
it I'm going to Google search it right
there on the spot and pull it up and so
uh we've had a hard time trying to book
RFK Jr for sure yeah yeah it's going to
be a hard one for sure and uh you know
there's another thing too uh he's been
invited to the libertarian party of
California Convention in fact they're
doing a debate there that has him
Cornell West Jill Stein and any
libertarian candidate that was willing
to pay
$55,000 to be in a debate for our own
party at our own State Convention when
they're not charging them which is kind
of weird right I would say it's kind of
weird anyways uh so he's gonna debate I
think Jacob hornberger and maybe Michael
rectenwald because they paid the fee I
refuseed to pay the fee Johnny medler
says RFK Jr endorsed Hillary Clinton
three times he's one of them no matter
what he says now yeah but he's pulling
votes from Joe Biden I think he's
pulling votes from both sides it's it's
it's mostly Joe mostly bid I think it's
pulling now mostly Biden I think in in a
in a general election he's pulling from
both sides I really yeah probably a
little but I think he's really got that
Democrat flare yeah but there's a
right-wing contingent that really like
this guy because of his his Co stances I
mean oh yeah CO's content with Trump and
you guys are looking for a I want to put
the co regime in Guantanamo Bay so all
right let's uh let's read this domestic
tourist says please pray for my dog
Scout cast crew and listeners he is
currently battling bone cancer and I'm
not sure how long he has I'm a veteran
of Iraq in Afghanistan and he's my
service dog he saved my life sorry to
hear it man I I hope for the best I hope
he has a has a good recovery and uh just
cherish every moment you can have with
him praying for your dog man thanks for
Serv bones so Mr
bcus uh we were we on Friday you know
someone came down and said he's like
sprawled out on the ground P like
staring at the floor's face just flat on
the ground and we were kind of worried
like at any moment he could die I mean
we've we've artif artificially
lengthened his life as long as we can
he's got a defective heart he's got
defective kidneys and he's young but
this is you know eat garbage and live in
the street maybe when he was younger he
ate some some chemical or who knows and
so uh we came up and he was sitting
there and so I thought to myself you
know what he's on the special diet for
his kidneys but it's looking really bad
he really he he eats he's he's hungry
that's good that's a good sign but he's
not putting on weight so I thought we
should give him some raw beef because he
really really when he came up here was
trying to eat the Bill Tong like crazy
but he can't eat it it salted and it
spiced and I was like he's showing signs
of like this may be the end end of life
yeah and so if he loves beef he's got
his last meal coming buddy and so we
gave him a chunk of raw beef he ate it
he's looking better and I have read
studies about feeding cats raw meat
because it's literally what they eat and
so I'm hoping and it may be a stupid
thing to hope that if he is about to die
and I'm going to give him some good food
before he goes and let him fill his
belly with raw meat like he'd love to
eat I'm happy he gets it but I'm kind of
hoping that maybe that that kick starts
him yeah it's it's it's it's that just
eats it and it helps him put put weight
back on or something and so I I looked
into what is the lowest phosphorous meat
because that's that's what you got to
watch out for for his kidney problem and
it's beef yeah and so I was like
straight up non-salted low sodium just
regular old raw beef and he went nuts
for it I'm hoping that keeps him eating
and I'm hoping the raw meat is better
for him and helps him put weight back on
but uh if not then I'm just happy that
uh he had a good end he had he had a
good last meal of the raw meat because
this this stuff we feed him for his
kidney diet it's a little
you know dry pellets and then he's got
this canned food that looks like yeah
garbage and he eats it but he just like
you know yeah why would you not just
want something good I've got the liver
Kings beef liver ex like a supplement
pill and every once in a while I was
pulling undoing a capsule and putting a
little powder on man he goes nuts for
that beef he wants you should get on you
should get on the liver King's growth
hormones dude shot liver King get
Absolut absolutely jacked like that D
you should do that' be great
get like a supercharged vehicle and just
get super jacked it'd be great I'd love
to see it and just claim like liver and
clean eating the entire time we get you
some cream and clear you can take a bath
stuff I'm going to do a liver cleanse
I'll tell you guys about it on another
show fobes says hey Josh it's simple
just ask Tim whether Libertarians should
vote for Dick Cheney if he were the
libertarian nominee that's a funny joke
yeah but like no that's a funny joke
because Dave Smith asked Nick sarwark
the the pr chair of the lnc who I was at
war with on his show do you think think
Libertarians should vote for Dick Cheney
if he's the if he's the nominee and he
said Hitler Hillary Clinton anybody yes
they have an obligation as a Libertarian
to vote for them because it helps the
libertarian party and that's kind of
where Nick sarwar is very dumb that's
why we that's why we took over the party
I mean sarar was the reason why we took
over one of my favorite points to make
was I I'd constantly hear these Trump
supporters conservatives in general say
if the Libertarians has voted for Trump
in 2020 then Trump would be the
president and I said Libertarians don't
like the Republican party like what's
what you they have this worldview not
all of them but many of them that
Libertarians are conservatives and we
owe our vote to the Republicans too
that's the other thing they and it's and
it's like I'm like Libertarians don't
like 90% of what Republicans do I don't
understand why they would want to vote
for you a lot of us were Republicans and
in fact the modern Libertarians today
came from the Ron paaul movement Okay
and like we watched them arrest our
caucus members at caucuses around the
country for Ron Paul we watch them
change the National Convention rules to
keep delegates out like we not going
back we get one we got one more it's a
good one ra gnu says last any you must
get report on timcast give him platform
and expand viewers please he's hilarious
and I'd love to hear him rant about Pig
dick Trump and cadav Joe for two hours
I'm sure not alone in in Desiring that
so we've we've reached out to uh his
agent and we we are trying to get him on
the culture War I I think it would be I
think it would be two hours of laugh
right I think we'd be laughing the whole
time you know for the people who don't
like Trump so funny yeah the people that
we've like I gotta say for all the for
all the people who really hate Trump
he's a funny guy yeah and uh self-aware
so I feel like it wouldn't be this thing
where we're just yelling at each other
about we're being wrong I think we'd be
laughing our asses off with everything
he says he's been funny for years yeah I
I would really I would really enjoy that
so I hope I hope uh he he he gets back
to us and come on he made a whole career
off of being a bad actor yeah like
literally that was like his whole shtick
is like I know I'm a bad actor I act bad
in movies on purpose now because that's
who I am he did something what was he
doing the was something he did in the
'90s he was in my favorite movie True
Romance it's like my very favorite movie
ever made all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to Tim cast.com click join us
because the members on the uncensored
show is coming up in a few minutes and
you don't want to miss it so click join
us become a member watch the uncensored
show on the front page at
timcast.net work you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Josh do you want
to shout anything out yeah follow me on
Twitter at Joshua atlarge and of course
go check out my show break the cycle
with Joshua Smith on YouTube Rumble and
uh also Odyssey but we're live on
YouTube so I am Phil that remains on
Twix I'm Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can follow us on Spotify Apple music
Pandora YouTube Amazon music you know
when's that album coming out uh we're
going to release some music and of March
first week of April very last at the
very end of first quarter beginning of
second quarter uh be first release and
then the record should be June have you
have you announced which songs are
getting released uh no but you know
which one it is I know I'm just like I'm
waiting it's such a good
song We'll have we'll have we'll have
the mix hopefully in the next couple
weeks I got one more trip to finish up
two more songs and then we got to do
some vocals and stuff but you going
heavier or softer uh well now it's all
acoustic now dude can we play on the
show no it's his fault for asking that
holy once we've launched you want
to play it on the show we should it's
not acoustic I'm kidding oh you we
should do an acoustic album can you do
an acoustic version Pretty you can we
can do a couple songs we've done we've
done two weeks acoustic we've done uh
Forever in Your Hands acoustic we've
done a couple of them acoustic you can
we can get away with it but not everyone
like I can't do like no knock or can't
do this darken
heart
dark I'll just say this before we jump
to liby but I've heard the songs and I'm
dying I'm just like I was talking to
Allison and I was like when did Phil
show us all this like I was we were
playing it like Phil's like here's a
sample and I'm I'm playing it in the
house in my playlist before anyone can
hear it I'm honored to be able to but
dude you got to release it I'm excited
for like really the thing is it's just a
matter of getting everything done
everybody's got a bunch of things that
bunch of things they've got going on
moving pieces getting our drummer
getting time and stuff so but it's
coming it's it's almost done we've got
like just a couple more things to finish
up did you get the drummer to play a
disco beat no you have a drummer classic
classic would like the not anymore all
right liby I haven't seen you in a while
sorry hi I'm Libby than guys I adore you
oh you're when's your album dropping um
my album is dropping in just a couple
weeks all right and I'm really excited
about it I hope that you guys all come
to I don't know what do you do when
album you have a party CD release CD
release release any guest spots from Ben
Shapiro uh no Ben Shapiro won't be there
um sadly it's a it's it's an album of
Libby reading quotes from famous
philosophers and political pundits for
two hours and you know on the on the B
side it's just me doing some ibson
monologues from
Dollhouse um so it's going to be really
pretty stellar and if you want to hear
more about that if you want to hear more
about that you can follow me at Libby
emons on Twitter and see all the work
we're doing at the post millennium .c
we'd be glad if you subscribe to the
post
millennial.age
H yeah let's uh let's do it I'm
surge.com uh follow me on Soundcloud why
not uh and everywhere else I argue with
people on Twix it's fun let's get to the
after show big uh Big Ups to everybody
here good to be back good to see you
Josh you love you man I'm going to be
debating Destiny on February 11th that's
next Sunday I think or Saturday in uh
Cincinnati that's going to be great so
it's going to be a debate conversation
about election Integrity I've been doing
research man and when you start going
down the rabbit hole of finding names of
people that work at companies that work
with companies it's like whoa what are
the ethics of calling out these people
Destiny does not know what he's getting
himself into dude this is going to be
the hottest event Cincinnati has seen
he's not going to be able to handle
debating Ian yes Deon so it's a debate
conversation we'll see where it flows
I'm really looking forward to so check
it out I'll let you know more as the
week goes on and we'll uh we'll see you
on the after show all right we'll see
you all over at timcast.net